peu
[Musique]
m
bon dos
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission où tout le
monde parle avec nous ce soir
laurent magie
non solo
la baronne la nouvelle fiancée de
sulitzer
françoise hardy
jean françois bizot a
incroyable révélation sur les médias
américains
[Musique]
elle ne foulent rôle
le leader de l'aidesep
notre fameux blind test consacré ce soir
la black music mesdames l'ex clan
[Applaudissements]
dis moi tu y ailles caisses du fonds
cordes en matinée
[Applaudissements]
ça va
avant de revenir habiter je vous propose
de regarder tout le monde en a parlé ce
sont les meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente et s'est préparé par monsieur
jean noël
manille tandis hertz danse connaît
de la compassion pour les flics qui font
bien leur boulot à la fée qui fait bien
son boulot il en faut ce serait
l'anarchie
ouais ouais tout marque quand tu te fais
tu te fait tabasser tu fais voler chez
toi qu'est-ce que le premier réflexe est
quoi j'appelle la police
ok alors tout le monde crache je suis
afrique qui fait bien son nom n'y a pas
de problème par contre les flics qui
font des bavures bassin souvent way
ce soir nous avons deux représentant
d'un syndicat de police
les voilà
[Musique]
vas-y dubois et m'écoeure moi j'ai parlé
il faut lui parler vous êtes là pour
débattre c'est un moyen très moyen ce
mois de suite ouais vous avez quelque
chose à ajouter
voyons pas
c'est vrai que quand je suis né tatar
été tes conneries oui totalement
ton papa quand il était petit il faisait
partie d'un gang de voyous
il a beaucoup de charme 1 7 me un an et
demi oui ça va c'est un vrai lover lover
arrête
noémie il est un pareil il est génial ce
tome i know quand on va en voyage
officiel comme ça après les dîners quand
on arrive dans la chambre des filles qui
attendent c'est normal c'est les
coutumes asiatiques sont très sympas
mais c'est l'achat pour ne pas garder
avec est ce qu'on fait le soir quand je
travaille dans la chambre hier j'étais
fatigué tu grandis trois airbus en
vitesse à pomper et chirac il est pas un
peu crevé là depuis que les américains
ont gagné la guerre là je trouve qu'il
est moins forte en lui leur lutte assez
impressionnant comme jamais fatigué
marche à quoi c'est un politique un qui
aime son pays il aime ce qu'il fait il
le fait et increvable
il me parle de sa maison à ussat fameux
maître il sort il bosse alors là vous
êtes tout seul voilà quelques mois
si je sens bien que tu es chaude je te
croire
c'est un petit brugnon qui ne demande
qu'à être croquée maintenant on a trouvé
le joli nom est levé dans une femme
maintenant elle est vraiment incroyable
à une magnifique réponse car l'essence
ivan auriel une vache dans une fois
comment ça va shirel donc tué ma mère ça
va bien ma main
moi je m'appelle pas trop en ce moment
quand même que vient dormir presque tous
les soirs à la maison maman à bord est
trop vieux je vous en fais toi aussi
[Musique]
honnêtement ça doit faire un drôle
d'effet comme ça d'être d'être adulé
ouais ça fait un gros déchet ouais c'est
vrai c'est dur à vivre ça 1
c'est étrange ouais c'est étrange c'est
pas nécessairement du ravi pleurs les
mots claquent assure qu'un petit coin
vous prenez un peu de dh ha ça va
réveiller votre libido et copain de
stomy bugzy arrivée d'affairé en sacs
jaunes habillé il faut montrer tes bras
pc devienne cuisses des fesses quand on
entend ce genre d'avion tamise un peu
on prend l'argent et on s'en va c'est ce
que dieu et ben si il est mort il se
décompose bonsoir au revoir vous qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait tomber alors son
stérilet est bien ce livre est fait pour
poser la question de la question
suivante il ne s'agit pas de croire
il s'agit de savoir de quoi il sèche ça
le dérange quand vous parlez de vous
parler de dieu goube le public aime
profondément vous faut laisser un peu de
mysticisme
j'ai voulu revenir à la sexualité
primaire 1 parce que je trouve
personnellement qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons une sexualité très sophistiqué qui
tue la sexualité et cérébrales oui c'est
vrai et j'en ai eu assez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les hommes passent plus
de temps à se dire mais qu'est ce que je
vais bien pouvoir lui faire que de faire
dans tous les cas un à béatrice pour la
pour la presse il faudra trouver des
trucs un peu plus rock'n'roll sale goût
des actions par une légende les légendes
ça se fait pas avec lui demandez lui
s'il a quelque chose de rock'n'roll aime
raconter sur lui à moi j'ai plein de
trucs à raconter
raconte moi
vous étiez rennes est ce que je pourrais
être votre conseiller intime
[Rires]
j'y réfléchis je regarde ton visage et
j'y pense pourquoi pas à
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant la honda fit
mais alors
très bien bon tu sais qu'il ya ce soir à
la fin de l'émission
winnipeg un progrès énorme ce soir
laurent et en attendant
et non
voici le lit de noël
[Applaudissements]
elle appelle oies et non le plus en plus
jolie noémie alors tout le monde connaît
désormais la légende de noémie lenoir
donc elle est courte mais belle noémie
16 ans au rang 1 matin dans un bureau de
poste à gif sur yvette pour acheter des
timbres et là il ne fait s'adresse à
elle et lui dit noémie vous devriez être
mannequin ça n'était pas la fellation
car en fait c'est pas une fait c'était
une dame qui avait été mannequin 40 en
avant dans l' agence ford et et noémie
lui répond d'accord madame oui madame
je vais être mannequin mais d'abord je
vais passer mon bac parce que noémie est
une bonne élève est une gentille fille
voilà alors il passe son bac elle part à
new york elle devient mannequin star
belle histoire
enfin faut faire attention quand même
parce que l'histoire les gens là raconte
un peu moins bien en ce moment là j'ai
lu l'autre jour dans télé 7 jours que
vous travaillez à la pomme serait il pas
la passe était à l'aise alors moi je
savais à noémie cac à new york vous
aviez un petit copain évidemment vous
vous l'aviez dit d'ailleurs on va pas
revenir là dessus de façon se terminer
maintenant bon mais lorsque je savais
pas en revanche et sa gelée vraiment
appris dans télé 7 jours c'est que vous
l'avez suivi ce petit copain l'actor
studio le fameux cours de comédie
pendant un an je savais pas du tout ça à
vous avez appris la comédie avec thor
studio avec 106 diorite cette affaire
c'est un peu plus psychologique métier
donc fait voir le même imaginer par
exemple à vous êtes en colère fait - la
fille est en colère pour voir maintenant
je vais pas m'énerver retraite bel et
bien fait après lui mais toi en colère
après le binôme i
attendez attendez on ressent comme ça
t'en reste à se concentrer c'est
l'acteur studio faut que ça vienne de
l'intérieur c'est très très difficile ça
vient de l'intérieur syrien de
l'intérieur programme des concerts je me
concentre aussi d'accord bon on arrête
menu merlet un peuple et les
bénédictions tu les as fan comme moi
studio et bien c'est impressionnant
c'est pas mal ça devienne m'embêter les
serbes chez les c'est de me tirer dans
les toilettes et cette année m'embête
ah bah ouais il a voulu tirer dans les
coins si vous voulez mon
je suis désolé je suis un esthète de la
vérité dit la vérité jeudi l'amérique
attrapé dans les poubelles
c'est pas bien de mentir
très bien oui non et il a donc noemi
après ses cours à l'actor studio vous
rentrez en france et là vous travaillez
sur un studio où travaillent également
alain chabat et vous lui prenais la tête
en lui disant je veux être absolument
dans ton film c'est pas la télé après
relais en juillet
les bases d'aqmi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai bon en plus c'est pas
vrai et donc vous voyez alain chabat et
vous lui demander d'être dans astérix
déjouer la courtisane deux-tiers
extraordinaire le film a fait 15
millions d'entrées donc voilà c'est tout
cela c'est tout paris / bien sûr c'est
grâce à vous c'est tout ce qu'on peut
dire est là donc vous êtes noémie lenoir
dans gomez et tavarès avec titoff et
stomy bugzy alors là c'est pas l'actor
studio les courses et des cours de
combats que vous avez pris un ouais
enfin deux jours à deux jours des jours
bonjour j'ai saintrick veut pas nous
montrer ce que c'est le taekwondo là ça
repose sur la zoologie du vieux nous en
fait du genou d'accord toi si les noms
de données - et nous la pintade en rut
ce manuel mann heat aux diverses danses
connu
josé l'addition fait 30 euros caron
san jose est là j'ai bien beau geste
marque l'arrêt ça parce que l'inspecteur
harry à côté de moi c'est une [ __ ]
moi quand je m'énerve ça pique vous
allez faire équipe avec matt stava reste
c'est un peu le héros du coin ben voyons
et toi là bas tu en état d'arrestation
pourquoi ça pour coups et blessures sur
agent de police
mais stipule à ses droits s'il te plaît
à nos morts
je vous parlais à certains ramirez qui
pose des problèmes gomez entraînement
pour acquérir tomates assure toi quand
on sait qu'ils t'ont temps en temps ses
mentors
combien tu as sur toi 250 noms ça ira
pour aujourd'hui mais demain ça sera le
double non il combine avec mon équipe
rouvrent art et je te présente ma soeur
et artistes j'ai regardé son cul mois de
juin passé brenner avec stomy bugzy
titoff noémie lenoir elodie navarre jean
yanne voilà il ya un monde fou dans ce
film donc avec stomy vous vous êtes
rencontrés
noémie un peu avant le le tournage mais
ça s'est concrétisé sur le tournage
pendant l'été dernier donc à marseille
comment vous avez pu garder ça secret
sur le plateau d'un sérieux comment vous
avez fait ça doit être super dur mais
les gens et je savais tu ta fille le
savez quand même non mais personne ne
savait où on a commencé à le savoir
comme vous êtes parti à la réunion chez
votre maman pour présenter ce tome i à
votre votre maman par an pendant les
fêtes quoi ça s'est bien passé là bas
avec les miens bon alors la belle
histoire continue vous dit de toute
façon j'obtiens toujours ce que je veut
effectivement depuis que je vous connais
je sais donc pas si c'est encore des
c'est comme ma mère vient de malgaches
et qu'elle est malgache et que je
travail à la poste non hein
enfin j'aimerais comme tout le monde tu
aimerais être malgache a travaillé à la
poste
et connaissez
les mannequins et bien des millions de
dollars le mètre malgache et travailler
c'est parti ça va être dans tous les
journaux ça maintenant tu vas être
malgache tu as bossé dans télé poche la
maintenance et parlez vous avez jamais
dit noémie j'obtiens tout ce que je veux
c'est dans télé loisirs
mais c'est vrai vous obtenez tout ce que
vous voulez c'est vrai tout regarder je
vous donne un exemple par exemple stomy
bugzy il a déclaré ce tome il a déclaré
depuis que je suis avec noemi je suis
devenu monogame assez fort bravo c'est
bien quand même a vraiment pas ce que je
vais vous dire
bien dans ce tome une stomie tu sais
bien comment ils étaient avant toi se
tenait alors la semaine
c'est vous
non mais
bien
noémie alors la semaine dernière stomy
bugzy était avec nous ça s'est très très
bien passé d'ailleurs été très très
sympathique
on lui a fait une interview de noémie
lenoir voilà exactement comment ça va
bien
bien très bien merci ça va très bien je
taimme comment vous avez fait pour
séduire noémie ben j'ai rien fait parce
que c'est elle qui m'a séduite fait le
premier pas il parraine un ami sam raimi
qui a fait près pas c'était houston
chennai me stomie noémie vous a présenté
sa mère est ce que vous avez fait la
même chose
oui ça s'est bien passé aussi et bien
ouais ouais
vos parents ont bien aimé noémie way oui
vous allez vous marier et noémie elles
seraient d'accord dans le mariage un
homme et non plus elles pensent comme
toi
d'accord pas d'accord pour l'instant
ouais on a le temps franchement je me
noémie c'est votre type de meuf
c'est moi je crois ouais aller
ce tome il sait quoi que vous regardez
en premier chez une femme
je regarde c'est sans ses fesses c'est
pour quand le tatouage noémie sur le
bras jamais jamais tu vas jamais de
faire tatouer nous avons jamais se faire
tatouer le nom de son fils de son enfant
oui mais pas de la personne avec noémie
un tatouage sur la hanche non non et
mille à cet hommage
l a7 tatouage aurait mis j'aimerais bien
les voir les mystères des doigts
[Applaudissements]
les rapporteurs
dites-moi stomie elle c'est noémie
qu'avant tout le monde vous appelez
chaud lapin dans barry non ouais ouais
elle dirige maintenant j'ai arrêté j'ai
arrêté à une fait confiance qu'est ce
qu'elle te ferait s'il apprenait que tu
l'a trompé genoni
je prends acte mais eminem qui traîne à
bah ouais faut pas se complaît à une
infidélité ca te quitterais comme ça
comme ça c'est avec une barbe aussi en
même temps la content et je les ai vu
l'autre jour elle a l'air vachement
content de la nuit c'est oui très
épanouie et finalement rien tu te quitte
bien là c'est franchement tu continues à
31 peu d'attention la raison s'arrêter
ou il arrêtait tout d'aller voir les
autres si de thé vraiment monogame
vraiment ténue monogame cet ami ouais
[ __ ] c'est bien le moins et les femmes
ouais je pense qu'elle me croit dernière
question ce tome i est ce que c'est vrai
que vous avez donné un nom à votre sexe
voilà la gmp famille se nichent pas dire
ses secrets ça avec mes potes et avec ma
femme
ça commence par qualité à des des
doudous nos du doubs c'est beaucoup plus
fort que ça un bus rue depuis clearer
dark vador ne sort à peu près la taille
d'un dinosaure badila faut consulter le
milieu noire la vie de gomes
gilles paquet brenner
chacun maintenant bruno solo
[Applaudissements]
mais non solo alors comment il va à
bruno solo parce que maintenant je vais
te parler à la troisième personne parce
que tu es quand même un poids lourd du
marché jouer napoléon pris un peu plus
barrés donc est ce que bruno solo pense
qu'il est devenu un des acteurs les plus
bankable du marché c'est en une question
d'enfoirés qui vous ressemble bien
thierry d'entrée jarry j'ai même pas le
temps de me détendre je sais pas je vais
pas là-bas je suis pas persuadé qu'on
puisse encore dire qu'on monte un film
sur mon nom à mort en cas c'est sûr que
mon nom n'empêche pas qu'un film se
montrent
ouais ouais ça j'aimerais bien que
j'aimerais bien quand même que bruno
solo non répondent à la troisième
personne
au niveau du talent et ce qu'ils pensent
qu'il a atteint la maturité bruno solo
bruno solo pense qu'il est à qu'il
atteint la maturité qui font qu'ils se
méfient pour parvenir totalement pourri
à aa
il se trouve beau désormais bruno solo
il s'est toujours trouvé beau et le
désormais étant trop ils n'y pensent pas
qu'il ressemble à un petit gros rigolo
bruno solo non il pense pas qu'ils
reçoivent un petit gros rigolo il pense
qu'il ressemble à quelqu'un des lancers
et c'est parce qu'il a beaucoup
d'imagination qui les comédiens d'accord
à la saed 1
il quitte sa vie en ce moment bruno solo
il a connu des périodes pire dans sa vie
il n'a pas le droit de se plaindre ce
moment c'est rien que du bonheur
il choque bien depuis qu'il cartonne à
fonds d'océan il est très fidèle en
matière de chauffage bruno cela m a dit
de lui il est il chope depuis quelques
années un de manière un voilà vous savez
comme ça et il sent proche d'alain delon
quand il parle de lui à la troisième
personne comme ça bruno solo dans la
force de bruno solo c'est de ne jamais
se prendre pour alain delon
et ben moi en fait il est bon son
nouveau film à bruno solo il pense que
le film qu'il vient de tourner c'est
rien que du bonheur pour lui même et
pour les autres arrivent accord là c'est
un film prosélyte en matière de bonheur
ah ouais d'accord et il fait le pitre où
c'est moi qu'il fait il le fait à il le
fait non il le fait il le fait lui il le
fait lui il le fait lui ne fait pas lui
la bombe et rien que du bonheur donc de
2 me par an c'est l'histoire d'un
critique de cinéma qui se fait larguer
par sa nana qui jouait par alexandra
lamy et qui essaie de retrouver son
pouvoir de séduction sa confiance en lui
voilà un
c'est un personnage complètement paumé
égoïste nombriliste contre l'allemand
nombriliste et qui est persuadé c'est ce
qui est épouvantable dans ce personnage
il est persuadé d'être le seul à
souffrir comme il souffre il pense qu'il
souffre beaucoup plus que tout le monde
a comme beaucoup de gens qui connaissent
tout d'un coup un passage à vide ils
sont persuadés que leur malheur est plus
important que celui des autres les un
vrai qu'il ya une certaine complaisance
dans leurs petits malheurs se gratter
les croûtes ou et voilà est encore ou st
pauli oui oui c'est vrai ça pour une
fois l'image et fut moche mais c'est
bien pierre 1 alors au début donc desire
s est le personnage joué par bruno solo
à peu près la quarantaine critique de
cinéma
il trouve que sa fiancée manu donc
alexandra lamy s'occupe trop de son
boulot à elle est avocate
donc il ya une dispute et l'uil dit
écoute maintenant où tu acceptes ta vie
où tu te casses 1 avec ton chien qui
s'appelle brad pitt d'ailleurs le chien
et lui ska voila voila il s'en va et
puis il se réfugie chez un de ses
meilleurs amis qui est un comédien
schizophrène comme beaucoup de comédiens
sauf que lui il se soigne pas un et il
l'héberge et il apprend à re séduire
grâce à nos personnages donc jean
baptiste et y rajoute le médian
schizophrène et michel scotto di carlo
joue son ami producteur italien qu'il
découvre là comme ça et ils sont tous
les deux dans une période difficile de
leur vie ils décident de s'entraider
pour apprendre à re séduire et
parallèlement à ça il continue à faire
son métier de critique
on a un animal qui rit on a les mêmes
pour dire que c'est trop long quand
c'est pas toi qui peux le pitch
non ce qui est génial c'est qu'on voit à
quel point l'humeur du critique influe
sur la critique qui fait ouais c'est à
ce moment-là choix car les données par
an pour présenter son métier je dis bien
tous les crédits qui sont comme ça voilà
donc ça s'appelle rien que du bonheur de
nos parents si une comédie douce amère
comme on dit son sentiment
le parisianisme le narcissisme tous les
maux qui nous guette
manitou a dit serge danse connaît
je sais pas mais je me sens plus chez
moi chez toi si tu t'en vas tu emmènes
rapid a dormi là toi mais je te le faire
pour des trente ans mais les carnets
computer vous acquitter un si ça peut
vous consoler le précédent a tenu à
peine un an
quand on est jeune on n'y voit pour tout
les faits les banques qu'elles rassurent
les copies l'émail et les ex les plaqués
tout toi tout le gâteau de l'entreprise
haute voix elle doit les baissée devant
l'imminence des temps d'aisé je suis sûr
qu'on te le dis très souvent tanaisie
électrique et on a dû vous dire souvent
mais vous avez des yeux vraiment
électrique je trouve je pense à un truc
n'a dû vous le dire souvent vous avez
vraiment les yeux vous êtes toujours là
on va j'adore ça j'ai l'impression de
bruce willis là de toute façon pour les
français vous avez beau et les
championnats de la wii vous pensé quand
vous tous pensent qu'à toi moi je passe
ma vie à les soutenir ils étaient peu
nombreux qui compte donc les non
désirées terre n'ont pas tous le fils de
société en laconie française grande
casse couille on les forme mon dieu ils
m'ont offert à ibo le chien robot
japonais est pas où aller et pile c'est
drôle parce que vous ressemblez pas la
manière de vous écrire est un et il
ressemble à quoi la manière dont j'écris
grande alors ce fait mais pire que
novell chine c'est un crime contre
l'humanité comment devenir critique de
cinéma ne quitte pas je te passe désiré
l'oncle non je continue à ratisser non
grata pas ton métier thème path écho
pinton pas ta mère t'aiment pas sa
défaite ça fait chier son baldaquin
trop mignons tous les deux rien que du
bonheur le bénis par an avec bruno solo
qui est notre invité ce soir alors et le
film la caméra café santé ou alors la
termine quasiment terminée de l'écrit on
fait la prépa octobre novembre 2010 2003
et on attendra janvier février 2004
encore réalisation avec yvan le bolloc'h
qui s'assure qu'en octobre novembre 2004
vous êtes ici re
[Musique]
en attendant le film le dvd d'entretien
des sms à ses septièmes et sur 100
sketch on l'a pris 40 qu'on a estimé une
fois de plus avec yves henry alain
kappauf co créateur de la série on a
estimé que c'étaient les meilleurs
donc si elle succès ce truc là c'est
incroyable c'est bien et dont et ça
commence à se vendre dans le monde
entier en faisant le monde on est
extrêmement fier parce que c'est on l'a
fait avec nos petites mains avec nos
petites têtes et c'est à nous de a
jusqu'à z
voilà alors la semaine dernière donc je
m'y étais là il a fait l'interview
noémie lenoir ensuite noémie a fait
l'interview stomie vous vous allez faire
l'interview yvan le bolloc'h
ça va ça va bien j'aime bruno depuis
trois jours et voilà je me sens mieux et
vous aimeriez être à la place de bruno
en ce moment vous avez vu son physique
et où il s'est quand même le garçon
alors à quoi regarder moi et tous et
tous pour moi qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vais que je lui envie dites moi
ils vont vous vous doutiez qui
réussirent est aussi bien solo non ça a
été une surprise pour moi et notamment
ma famille et encore aujourd'hui je n'en
reviens pas je pense que c'est un clown
il a changé quand même d'un solo
physiquement pas beaucoup et c'est sa
force à ils ne changent pas brûler au
pardon mais autrement non il est resté
il est resté le même et c'est dans un
petit peu en retrait faisant croire
qu'il est le chef
il se la pète un peu non et un jour met
plein la gueule et jean fouque l'insa
lyon qui se la pète un peu bof pas plus
que moi
il accepte facilement les critiques bono
solo oui sauf sur son physique et c'est
ce qui le rend visiblement ils prêtent
facilement de la thune et alors ça c'est
dur tu le but ancien inquiets boîte de
jean zay mais à moins de beurs battant
matin j'essaie de voir oui d'avoir
l'époque jean et ce avant de casser ils
en ont ils prêtent facilement de la
thune
oui et d'ailleurs si je me mets plus
changer de voiture dernièrement c'est un
peu grâce à lui si j'ai l'accent dit un
modèle avec le spoiler
que du bonheur de délits par an avec
alexandra lamy et bruno solo 14
et maintenant
voici françoise hardy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir
ça va très heureux nous avons avec nous
alors qu'on soit zardi double actu donc
d'abord un livre qui s'appelle les
rythmes du zodiaque
c'est au cherche midi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça c'est pour le team a pu aussi
indice c'est un best-of qui s'appelle
message personnel c'est chez virgin
[Musique]
et
sachez alors à commencer par le disque
donc c'est une compilation mais qui a
une particularité c'est que les morceaux
ont été choisis par vous pour une fois
d'habitude c'est des patrons des maisons
de disques qui font ça soit vous en
parlait sans vous en parler voilà oui
donc j'ai choisi des chansons qui ne
sont pas tellement connu du public et
qui à mon avis sont aussi bonne sinon
meilleur que ça qu'ils sont plus connus
oui parce que des gros tubes donc genre
il ya des gros tubes genre comment te
dire adieu partir quand même jamais
entendu ça de ma vie lors comment te
dire adieu
je ne sais pas c'est le simplement dire
moi partir quand même laurent givet
devenu françoise hardy ça me revient par
bribes vous les copains je ne les
oublierai jamais et puis alors il ya des
chansons moins connues effectivement
comme le crabe
tu connais il a le crâne dans le crachin
les marseillais voilà des chansons qui
ont fait que françoise hardy devenu une
icône culte chez les jeunes musiciens
chez le jeune chanteur a commencé par
etienne daho blur aussi tu sais que les
mecs de blur sont fans de françoise
suisse et mervyn je me suis mis
seulement six jeunes consomment bill
pritchard ou befree tout le monde adore
franchement oui c'est ça c'est partir un
jour
groupe le beau-père si vous êtes
d'horaires oui j'ai d'ailleurs
enregistré une chanson avec eux voilà
c'est dingue
si vous êtes jéhovah marianne faithfull
deux françaises vraiment mieux non plus
je n'ai pas non plus maintenant
ito à 10 heures
vous partez en voyage
puisque nous
quittant ce soir
[Musique]
mon coeur fait son apprentissage
je
je veux sourire avec ou 1
que je
vos bagages
marche avant
du coup
vva
pour les rangs seniors
je vais préparer
maugeois puisqu'avant partir en voyage
françoise hardy cédant message personnel
la compliquer at elle même
il s'appelle le mec était avec elle sur
le cliché pas mais j'ai le nom bout de
la langue
il s'appelle je sais pas il va sortir un
disque bientôt d'ailleurs
ouais c'est imminent alors deuxième
actualité de françoise hardy donc le
livre les rythmes du zodiaque c'est au
cherche midi alors à prendre les choses
dans l'ordre parce que c'est vrai que
c'est l'astrologie des fois ça peut
sembler un peu compliqué alors ça avec
moi ça l'est et donc quand on vous
demande sur quoi est basée l'astrologie
françoise hardy vous dit tout se passe
comme si le système nerveux du
nouveau-né fixer les rythmes de son
environnement solaire au moment précis
de sa naissance en environnement solaire
c'est le système solaire bien entendu
les gens sont tellement cons donc c'est
ça quand on me canton quand on arrive
comme ça au jour à ce moment là on sait
comme une empreinte voilà c'est ça c'est
comme ça ça semble se passer peut rien
affirmer ses classes a le mérite d'être
clair dit il sans conviction je vais te
dire au contraire j'étais pas mal et je
me dis quand on est dans le ventre
pourquoi on serait pas soumis aussi l
influence cela pourrait il faut attendre
de sortir du vent m'a pas ce qu'on
reçoit directement à dire que la
protection de la maman oui c'est vrai
filtre alors le problème à le problème
c'est que depuis plusieurs siècles
l'astrologie est pratiqué par des
astrologues qui ne connaissent rien
reste rhône au mit j'étais sûr qu'on
parlera d'elisabeth tessier le sont déjà
arrivés oui c'est vrai ça j connaissent
rien les mecs
oui c'est à dire que au départ
l'astrologie était pratiquée par des
astronomes et un certain moment elle a
été interdite
du coup elle est tombée dans les mains
de gens qui se sont contentés les
symboles astrologique au sens sans
spécialement on en met sans savoir ce
que ça recoupe est réellement sans
savoir pourquoi on utilisait ses
symboles et il a fallu attendre le xxème
siècle au milieu du 20ème siècle pour
que surgisse comme par miracle
jean pierre nicolas cage est ici depuis
quatre ans ça fait 30 ans que non mais
c'est le seul qui a fait avancer
l'astrologie depuis depuis plusieurs
siècles
non mais non la seule chose qu'il faut
préciser c'est que l'astrologie informe
sur l'un de nos conditionnements qui est
justement conditionnement seles c'est à
dire la situation du système solaire
au moment de notre naissance laquelle se
résume à des rythmes et les quel rythme
nous prédispose à avoir certains
réflexes par rapport au monde paraît par
exemple capricorne dont vous êtes a
tendance à tendance à avoir un réflexe
de fermeture par rapport au monde alors
que les gémeaux que vous êtes aussi on
en sens contraire de l'amour c'est ça
qui lui donne un côté échanger c'est ça
mikkelson stomie vous savez et vous ça
marche mais sont très complémentaires y
en a un qui peut sécuriser l'autre et
puis l'autre qui peut mettre en danger
l'un donc c'est nécessaire autant alex
une affaire qui peut qui peut tourner ce
dont je me rends compte c'est qu'à
chaque fois toute façon il ya toujours
quelque chose à dire
évidemment elle vous dit que le fait que
ce soit capricorne et luigi mots je ne
sais plus vierge aimons bien gémeaux si
oui c'est contradictoire dans son
ensemble ça veut tout dire mais non mais
non mais c'est là on retombe dans les
trucs parce qu'on peut être beaucoup
plus précis que ça bon la vierge à
l'aidant l'autoprotection donc à l'aller
pendant parlait la dette on a des
réflexes sécuritaires de de fermeture au
monde le besoin de se protéger par
rapport il ya le contraire ou dix ans
oui c'est ciel dénoncer leur ascendant
balance soit sans danger mot car c'est
par là m'a dit vous êtes beaucoup mieux
qu elisabeth teissier mais je suis
patient parce que avec vous c'est très
difficile devrait s'exprimer pour la
première fois je me sens très solidaire
des abbesses alors françoise hardy il ya
une chanson de vous que vous détestez
deux garçons
et il
françoise hardy on va vous faire une
interview tous les garçons et filles de
mon âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françoise est ce que comme tous les
garçons et les filles de votre âge vous
regarder des chiffres et des lettres
absolument est ce que comme tous les
garçons et les filles votre âge vous
regrettez les années 60
non je regrette les années à venir que
je ne vivrai pas vous allez dire un truc
terrible jour j'y pense s'en servir elle
m'a dit un truc un jour elle m'a dit
genre il nous reste puisque la table
pratiquement le même âge tu te rends
compte qu'il nous reste peut-être que 20
noël ou vingt fois à voir fleurir les
lignes chaque fois ça m'a fait flipper
j'y pense tous les jours je me dis 19
j'allais le trompe la mort il se risque
avec ça c'est pas mal françoise hardy
est ce que comme tous les garçons et les
filles de votre âge d'être fan de
jacques dutronc
j'ai prouvé je crois ce qu'est ce qu'il
devient est ce que comme tous les
garçons les filles votre âge de les
prendre votre retraite sur la côte
d'azur
mais c'est déjà faire est ce que comme
tous les garçons les filles de votre âge
vous portez des thermolactyl de damart
tous les hivers papa ce soir est ce que
comme tous les garçons les filles de
votre âge vous raconter toujours les
mêmes histoires à table gens racontent
aucune moi j'ai pris à votre localité
est ce que comme tous les garçons les
filles de votre âge j'avais les jambes
lourdes en fin de journée comme tous les
garçons et filles de votre âge est ce
que vous avez arrêté de vous droguer non
mais je vais peut-être commencer bientôt
est ce que comme tous les garçons et les
filles de votre âge pour soi zardi vous
lisez la rubrique nécrologique avant
l'horoscope
ça me rappelle emmanuel berl qui qui
voyait d'un très mauvais oeil mon
intérêt pour l'astrologie qui me
disaient j'ai mis mon horoscope
aujourd'hui était déjà très très âgé et
me dit on me conseille de prendre
conseil justement de gens plus âgés mais
y en a plus est ce que comme tous les
garçons les filles de votre avis est
susceptible quand on vous parle de votre
âge ça vous dérange pas 85 ans oui c'est
pour ça
bonsoir mesdames messieurs donc le livre
que je vous recommande s'appelle les
rythmes du zodiaque et sept unités au
cherche midi
quant au disque qui s'appelle message
personnel et c'est chez virgin
leur émission lui ce qui est bien c'est
ainsi
[Musique]
et maintenant
c'est chaud
d
schild
ont-ils bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
à
la ville depuis la disparition du baron
edmond votre épouse vous avez beaucoup
de temps libre
et comme vous avez beaucoup d'argent
vous visiter les endroits en europe où
ont eu lieu les plus belles histoires
d'amour voilà un c'est pas compliqué et
vous en rapporter un livre qui s'appelle
sur les chemins de l'amour et c'est
édité chez robert laffont
[Musique]
voilà alors tout le monde y passe ainsi
si et françois joseph lola montès et
louis de bavière la païva george sand
alfred de musset bien entendu roméo
juliette zelda et scott fitzgerald
joséphine napoléon la du baril week end
la charia n'est possible donc on
commence avec 6,6 dans qu'elle faisait
chambre commune avec françois josef et à
l'époque c'était une révolution ça
absolument et après non après non parce
que après il s'est passé tellement de
choses où elle est devenue complètement
une femme mystérieuse une femme
anorexique car elle a eu de tels drames
dans sa vie qu' effectivement elle
n'était pas mais j'ai très bien connu
cette impératrice à cause de ma belle
mère qui habitait le château de pau nier
ce qui venait régulièrement au chanteur
ronnie donc elle était une grande
habituée je dormais dans la chambre de
6,6 quand je me suis marié la mère donc
à l'époque faire chambre commune c'était
mal vu
je le suppose enfin je n'étais pas là
cette époque ah bon et bien là aussi si
si c'est elle qui choisissait la
maîtresse de son mari et c'est super
sympa à écouter et vous price à lady sa
plume écoutez les clubs de rencontre
qu'est ce que c'est c'est ça hein c'est
pas les femmes qui choisissent les
maîtresses et leurs bungalows
non mais en grande partie si les femmes
laisse faire aujourd'hui c'est ça le
drame c'est que malheureusement elle non
plus si vous voulez 7
cette légèreté pour pouvoir dire cette
femme est charmante
aujourd'hui on divorce on balance et
puis c'est terminé tu ferais ça toi
évidemment non mais on dit que les
hommes aux sons ou à mon mari qu'est ce
que vous êtes
marie vous êtes marie way s'est donc
conclue donc donc
alors
jénine et ça de choisir les maîtresses
de votre mari vous c'est pas l'idée
c'est du bon
[Applaudissements]
vous avez posé une question une force de
l'émission samedi
vous rentrez chez vous un soit envoyé
dutronc au lit avec le site et vous
m'avez répond je suis dit qu'est ce que
vous faites mais a répondu je me joins à
eux
oui ça met beaucoup choqué j'ai mis 6
mois mon mari dit c'est une chose je te
verrai au lit avec monsieur je dirais
que c'est pas toi
ah c'est ça c'est ça l'éducation est ce
que l'on a envie de savoir où on n'a pas
envie de savoir est ce qu'on a envie de
garder on a envie de voir la personne
s'éloigner c'est vrai moi je ferais la
même chose je vous verrai au lit avec
votre femme je dirais c'est pas lui dans
mon cas il ya 6 6 à lola montès la
pompadour bavaroise donc été avec louis
1er de bavière qui perdra sans trop de
mer maintenant vous dites qu'elle n'a
pas su tirer profit de ces rencontres
c'est pas comme vous attendez attendez
attendez moi j'ai eu très peu de
rencontres mais ils ont été très
productives super super league c'est les
femmes se galvaude elles ne savent pas
choisir ce mois là elle se donne tout de
suite à tout le monde n'y a pas beaucoup
de roach ils n'ont plus c'est difficile
nous reviennent toujours à cette phrase
imaginer coude rothschild dont vous avez
c'est vrai autant dans la rue les gens
du doigt il ya 40 millions d'hommes sur
la place de paris ou non en france
bon il n'y a pas non plus que des gens
qui peuvent pas faire votre bonheur des
hommes font votre bonheur faut pas être
rothschild pour ça alors il ya aussi la
païva la païva c'est celle pour qui en a
construit cet hôtel particulier en bas
des des champs elysées qui est devenu
bien triste d'ailleurs je suis allé
c'est devenu un peu un peu triste parce
que à l'époque de la païva vous dire
qu'avec des baignoires à 3 robin et
parce que la païva prenait des bains de
l'est de tilleul et peut-être de
champagne cessera ordinaire oui non mais
n'a pu des filles comme ça assise mais
malheureusement non les femmes ne font
plus fantasmer les hommes
il vous achète peut-être une n'est pas
une machine une machine
fut pas moins computer ou un truc comme
ça mais ça va alors ça s'arrête là
quoique ça les occupants les computer
françois ça fait deux ans que je pense
en computer pour faire 100 livres et je
peux vous dire qu'elle est on sait où
aller au moins vous parlez de george
sand aussi oui alors qui part donc
et alors ils font un ménage à trois je
savais pas et que les docteurs aller
taguer lola par ingrid bergman aussi
alan lieberman s'était dit ce qui lui
est arrivé parce que rossellini roberto
rossellini devenu fou d'amour pour elle
il l'a épousée il va faire un enfant
fameux robertino étaient divorcés
oui il a fait du gros sel et quand elle
a eu sept enfants après il l'aimait plus
parce que c'était la maman et mais c'est
normal c'est logique les femmes
s'imagine toujours quelles vont-être des
maîtresses toute la vie c'est pas vrai
on est maîtresse tant qu'il y as
séduction tant qu'il y a fantasme
après lorsqu'il y a un enfant la femme
c'est plus sont assis mais dont sciences
exactes n'ont pas besoin d'en faire
quand le gosse était dans la pièce à
côté vous pouvez pas faire des
galipettes c'est normal c'est vrai c'est
vrai on va chez vous l'enfant à la pièce
elle devait être assez loin
il ya des changements le métro entre le
sommet pour la chambre qui descend à
chaque les noms mais je vous dis c'est
selon c'est désolant mais c'est made in
the wind et c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu
quarante ans sinon je n'aurais pas fait
je n'avais pas fait trois jeux ouais
mais vous savez que françoise hardy et
jacques dutronc ils font vous faites
toujours un appartement à part c'est
bien moi je fais ça aussi c'est ça c'est
encore mieux et alors najin vous arriver
finalement au taj mahal et là vous
achetez le kama sutra alors ça j'y crois
mais vous allez en parler mais j'y crois
pas je n'avais pas à me dire que vous
avez attendu tout ce temps pour acheter
le kama sutra made in je vous donne ma
parole
et là j'ai réalisé que j'avais tout faux
bond mais tout faux en fait mais qu'est
ce que ça aurait été si vous l'avez tenu
quarante ans en kama sutra imaginaire
j'avais toute la famille chiens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon moi je suis venu de toutes ces
histoires quand on connaît la vôtre
c'est cent fois mieux votre histoire à
vous non c'est vrai que je suis une des
rares femmes d'abord je devrais être
dans dans le livre des records et se dit
marié 40 ans avec un homme comme était
mon mari c'était pas du site est pas
facile tous les jours vous savez la dina
la plage bien des photos d'animaux sauna
mais ce qui prouve qu'ils prouvent leur
ans et que j'ai fait ce tour du monde
pour l'agresser libyens sur wii les
photos ça c'est certain
je me suis donné beaucoup de mal pour
arriver à pondre un livre qui va faire
rêver mes lectrices parce que qu'est ce
qu'elles ont envie d'entendre c'est
parler d'amour
oui votre époux ici j'avais bien aimé
oui oui oui je pense pas qu'elle va
l'acheter tout de suite mais pourquoi ça
allait lui acheter
non je ne pense mois ci se tient à si tu
devrais médecin très bonne et je vais
plutôt me donner ce qu'ils me annie
l'année même pas question c'est très
physique de la saison ils ont fait part
tenu à retiers
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais petit on me disait que les
retient il ramasse et une aiguille par
terre mon père et ma mère me faisait
croire quand 10 1 milliards d'eur en
ramassant des aiguilles par terre j'ai
essayé ça n'a pas marché
tu connais des histoires de nadine non
oui vous étiez jeune comédienne nous
avons rencontré non mais ça commence
avant cela dit nenê en banlieue 1 donc
c'est bien avant d'être comédienne
ouvrière dans un deux pièces à aller
chercher l'eau dans la course a donc
c'était quand même assez le premier
amour de nadine été chiffonniers oui il
allait vous cherchez des fleurs dans les
poubelles et vous les avez fait c'est
une très belle histoire un 14 ans vous
vous retrouvez en train de travailler
dans une usine de housses de voitures
chennai bowyer et mêmes pour faire un
peu d'argent de poche le soir quand vous
rentrez vous l'avez le marbre de
l'escalier de l'immeuble ses parents et
voilà non non non mais attends c'est sûr
j'avais monté de causette
attention c'est pas les misérables mais
qu'en même temps il ya un côté cause
d'algues très bien sorti et alors donc
vous commencé par rencontrer le peintre
jean gabriel domergue qui vous pour
qu'ils vous devenez modèle
ensuite vous êtes effectivement danseuse
meneuse de revue comédienne à l'âge de
17 ans il l'a hélas à partir de là le
jeu est là et la nadine se dit j'ai j'ai
pas le physique de la star quoi je vois
là quoi je vais pas y arriver comme ça
et elle se dit murray si une solution
c'est vrai elle se dit il reste le
mariage sauf que le maïs ce sera un vote
il quoi ces dix ans de traque
un nom pas de troc mon dieu j'étais
charmante j'étais tout à fait tout à
fait agréable pour un homme pourquoi
est-ce que hier soir était la traque de
mon côté pas du tout parce que c'était
un animal rare dont le bouffer il faut
bien vous dire quand vous rencontrez une
femme c'est pas elle qui vient vous
chercher
c'est vous qui la découvrit ouais non
mais d'ailleurs la première fois c'est
bien je moi je
la première fois qui vous a vu demande
roig et du vous a dit vous êtes la femme
de ma vie
absolument voilà absolument je n'ai pas
cru d'ailleurs et cela était vrai
puisque ça a duré 40
il venait de se marier en plus et non
mais il tapait nadine un ardente a
trompé c'était dans des livres mes
enfants mes enfants je ne suis pas j'ai
toujours vous savez connaissez les trois
petits singes
ouais ouais c'est vrai qu'on vous a
plein la ruée vers l'or quand même à
l'époque oui on m'a toujours dit on m'a
toujours dit que j'étais fait pour avoir
beaucoup d'argent et vous auriez dû le
voir effectivement dans vos et la
journée vous voir vous allez me dire si
vous passez vous prédire le passé c'est
bien je crois que vous avez tessier sera
mieux pour ça le fait bien grandir ce
genre donc je continue à les jambes de
nadine de rothschild donc effectivement
vous rencontrez demande rothschild mais
évidemment il ya un handicap il vient de
se marier avec une fille sublime
d'ailleurs il est l'héritier d'une
prestigieuse dynastie financière il est
juif pas vous ce qui ne simplifie pas du
tout les choses après vous êtes converti
mais mais ça j'ai pas trouvé qu'il y
avait des problèmes
jésus était juif mais aussi absolument
joseph aussi alors je vais pas
s'arranger à l'amiable
et alors là pendant trois ans vous êtes
la femme de l'ombre
vous êtes dans un appartement à la
muette quoi la vue est d'où le nom de
parler à l'époque
vous savez aujourd'hui toutes les femmes
sont plus ou moins plus ou moins comment
on appelle comment du temps mais je ne
savais pas vous voulez en venir dont a
vraiment jamais été maîtresse norway
du conteur ou l'art dans une autre vie
romane le têt
donc voilà un jour vous êtes enceinte et
le baron vous épouser voilà non il ne
m'a pas non attention ça ne s'est pas du
tout ça c'est pas comme ça il a décidé
qu'un jour nous allions faire un enfant
d'accord j'ai pris la décision en son
enceinte mais comment lui pouvait faire
un enfant dans la clandestinité
je vous savez écouter aujourd'hui le 5 à
7 qu'est ce que vous faites l'après midi
entre 5 le buzz mesdames et la voilà
donc finalement vous rentrez dans la
famille rothschild vous convertissez
tout va bien et vous devenez la baronne
de rothschild et voilà et alors vous
mettez au point mort fameuse théorie à
ce moment là sur l'homme roi 1 l'homme
quand même roy l'homme est naturellement
un fidèle
c'est oui le mot faillite et âme au
féminin masculin pourrait dire à ma
femme en regardant la caméra là je vais
lui dire en sortant vous d'accord la
grande théorie nadine c'est que le vrai
féminisme c'est de mener les hommes par
le bout du nez en fait c'est ça le vrai
bien entendu on a tous les pouvoirs ici
mais c'est un euphémisme c'est pas
honnête tu penses
ils changent pas à prendre l'excusé le
laisser l'histoire elle tirait le diable
par la queue
pourquoi la queue car le diable
[Applaudissements]
allez
ça recoupe des emails nadine une
question car est sans cesse pourquoi là
que tu as beau pays mais voilà que je me
demande tout seul et à nadine pas renié
à bruno sanaa et adressés
personnellement mais sûrement dans les
prochaines années sans aucun doute j'ai
dû la trouvait d'ailleurs voilà donc
vous devenez une grande spécialiste de
la stratégie amoureuse à ce moment-là
nadine de rothschild les règles de
savoir vivre les bonnes manières en
facteur la table le plan de table
exactement étiquette absolument et on va
faire une interview dîner chez les
rothschild
nadine est ce que le retard est
tolérable
je pars du principe que les gens qui
arrivent à l'heure ne doivent pas
attendre celui qui n'est pas à leur faim
alors je me mets à table avec mes
invités et les gens arrivent après et
croyez moi ils n'arrivent pas deux fois
en retard et vous fermait pas la porte
quand même vous laisser arriver je les
laisse arrivé il ya toujours la
vaisselle alors on doit apporter quoi
quand on va dîner chez les gens en
général on aurait des fleurs à carlton
est décédé mais sinon retour vient dîner
mais quand on aime manger chez moi ça
arrive souvent jean deysel encore cédé à
me passer des amis quand c'est des amis
en n'importe quoi made in si j'habite
monsieur à dîner alors vivement la
faille ils m'envoient des fleurs dès le
lendemain ils font déjà partie moi je le
fais des aspects mais vous avez aussi le
lendemain effectivement le droit
d'envoyer alors faut-il manger de tout
ah on est obligé non si vous avez un ami
diabétiques la maîtresse de maison sa
forme afin pour on sait que non
belle mentalité réellement balotelli
avait dit que forcément bien alors la
question très importante
est ce que la télé peut rester calcul
encore dit c'est une émission comme tout
le monde encore une spéciale qui veut
gagner des millions et 100 pour un
champion je dînais avec vous peut-être
oui
ah oui oui en tête-à-tête en tête à tête
ont pour annexer la télé non parce que
je m'ennuierais peut-être vous avez
aujourd'hui
madrid subsol bien est ce qu'on peut
faire du pied sous la table d'une mais
comment c'est même recommandé aux femmes
âge aussi on sent des pièces est-ce que
la main baladeuse est autorisée ouais ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas comment dirais-je
sait pas tout ce qui est un peu
hypocrite sous la table ce sont paul
faire un c'est un homme cette jeune dame
ça vous est déjà arrivé de faire du plat
une femme en passant la balle lui mais
pas les mêmes chez moi un conte par
rapport à quoi dans la banque rothschild
en compte mais oui mais oui oui c'est
pas idiot je regarde un découvert
autorisé
voici vous payer en nature peut-être
mais j'ai claqué d'auteur
pourtant on file du ccg manière vraiment
dommage car en chine
pas mal c'est pas tombées dans l'oreille
de leur faire ça non je cherche mon sens
pleure mais je le trouve pas un fils
oubliée chez toi ensuite noir mais je
l'aimé pas non c'est un peu too much
fallait bien non nadine c'était quoi
s'était passé bon d'accord c'est une
[ __ ] la domination
c'est ensemble
c'est vraiment dommage et le gamin au
vélo des cours n'ont rien alors nadine
est ce qu'on peut se soucier que son pas
est ce que fossé s'est trompé
alors
oui bien parce qu'on peut dire tout le
temps on a l'exemple en société mais je
suis surprise aujourd'hui par la
génération des femmes qui vous disent
ouais on va dire oui bon quand vous
dites à un homme qui se disait est ce
que tu même si on vous demandait ce que
tu m'aimes
elle répondait je t'aime au lieu du ruy
je t'aime sur toute la différence
valls a fustigé tenir c'est le bordel
c'est pour ça qu'il ya la guerre il
pensait bien malade
plus sérieusement la d écoute moi
qu'elle est là ne la manque
ça va partir mais coûteux elle est là la
plus grosse gaffe qu'on puisse faire un
dîner chez toi de ne pas venir
ça c'est d'une belle raconté julien
réponse et nous irons demain les fleurs
sont partis
j'ai commandé une couronne
et chemin
voilà françoise hardy je vous laisser
filer parce que je prends soin à ses tu
sais que tous les garçons et les filles
de notre âge se couche assez tôt dans
françoise merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
le
j'accueille la nouvelle fiancée de paul
loup sulitzer et va comme à lescar
evans en soir
bruno solo lambin filles et nadine de
rothschild
j'ai fait une connerie l'on doit
commencer par présenter les femmes bien
sûr la baronne faut donner les titres
la baronne de rothschild bruno solo et
laurent baffie voilà et vous vous êtes
la nouvelle fiancée de paul loup
sulitzer
on est très heureux de vous connaître
alors vous avez deux points communs avec
nadine d'ailleurs vous êtes avec hammam
riches plus âgées que vous un et vous
écrivait des livres
[Musique]
donc eva vous êtes polonaise né en
silésie durant l'hiver 80 et vous avez
été victimes de tchernobyl
quand vous étiez petit à un moment après
l'explosion de tchernobyl votre corps
s'est recouverte du feu dans mon coeur
c'est juste les avant bras quand je les
ferais ça dans les livres et j'ai
plusieurs effets secondaires de nuages
de challenge league mais c'est vrai mais
les vraies victimes c'est pas moi les
mre victime se sent l'est
malheureusement ce sont les foetus d'un
maire qui est enceinte
il y avait plein d'enfants beaucoup
d'enfants qui sont nés avec des
malformations
oui voilà vous effectivement à part
votre taille bon bah oui ça va quand
même hein je me débrouille j'avais des
grands complexes de ma taille
journal de moins en moins avec chacun
neuf voilà alors éducation catholique un
épi l'âge de 13 ans évidemment vous
commencé à boire de la bière à fumer des
cigarettes
et puis aussi à mettre des soutiens
gorge rembourrés beaucoup de jeunes
france à vouziers des trucs pire
un jour on a fait un truc tout bête
on n'est pas venu pour un examen final
coloscopie
on a passé un an tant dans la toilette
de fille à parlait et
après on avait en vue d'une bouteille de
bière et on avait commencé à avoir des
idées bête que l'esprit et on appris
plein de papiers toilettes
tout le monde connaît entraide on a qu
on a ouvert la force de notre classe on
a acheté de papier toilette dans la
classe jusqu'à l'incroyable eva c'est
votre obsession
on y viendra à votre obsession du papier
toilette parce qu'un jour vous êtes avec
paul loup sulitzer lance dans le petit
studio où il vit maintenant et vous
videz trois bouteilles de vin chacun et
je me suis souvenu de sa de cette
histoire et c'est comme ça que je suis
venu avec les deux dragons papier
toilette il s'enroule tu sais si tu peux
dire que j'ai fait ça mais je connais
pas pas lu logements vacants si vous
voulez trois bouteilles de vin et après
tu la fille sophie une robe en papier
toilette taja marque ford c'est une
bonne histoire soir c'est dans le
bouquin c'est bien beau cas il n'aura
livres à acheter quand même bien alors
donc votre premier contact et va avec le
luxe et un voyage sur la côte d'azur
l'année qui a précédé votre rencontre
avec paul loup sulitzer là vous êtes
quand même beaucoup plus je dirais
dépravé où je sais c'est pas un secret
on va se le dit dans les lire
après la première semaine que je passe à
saint tropez
je voulais partir parce que ça c'était
pour moi saint-tropez c'était brigitte
verdoodt c'était gendarme de saint
tropez les indices tout ça et là où ça a
développé dans un sens plutôt mauvais
dans tous les cas quand vous pas peur
pas peur mais ça m'a pas plu interview
de huit jours quand tu vois pas de
funestes envie de rentrer alors autour
de saint tropez en août 2002 vous avez
21 ans donc et vous êtes déçu un petit
peu vous attendez plus grand chose des
hommes à ce moment là oui la playboy que
j'ai vu
que j'aille eu la chance de rencontrer à
centre ap c'était parce qu'il ya de
mieux dans la rade
voilà c'est sûr qu'avec pelouse ça fait
un choc quand même c'est sûr et
l'ajustement metula reste président
le prince charmant justement et là vous
rencontrer paul luu donc la première
rencontre ça se passe chez des amis et
vous avez lu son livre anna quand vous
étiez en pologne et donc effectivement
ça aide parce qu'effectivement il arrive
c'est lui qui a écrit anna ainsi si
pardon parce quand ils vous rappellent
quelques semaines après vous vous rendez
compte qu'il passe assez facilement du
vous au tuc en main
oui c'est vrai qu'en quand on s'est
rencontrés on se vouvoie y est c'était
jusque dans l'antre première longue
conversation au téléphone quoi commencer
ça y est donc là je vous ai fait la
rencontre entre paul loup sulitzer y va
le premier coup de fil derrière on a les
images et maria pas d'imagés le premier
flirt ya le premier flirt et là il vous
dit que lui son père était un vrai
polonais donc évidemment s'il fait ça
pour créer une relation entre entre vous
deux ans fait son père devenu polonais
vous savez qu'ils étaient roumains à son
père il était polonais marek et aux
mains il était bon maçon polonais il a
quitté la pologne qu'il était très jeune
donc l'état de le sang et il a vécu en
remanient et de roumanie et la venue en
france c'est pas lui qui a écrit sa
biographie
voilà donc paul loup sulitzer morale
comme ce divorce à la dallas il est
assez honnête avec vous dit qu'il a eu
deux autres femmes avant tout de suite
dit voilà j'ai eu deux autres femmes
j'ai quatre enfants qui pas dire il le
dit il le dit j'ai des problèmes
financiers
ben voilà il dit la vérité mais à ce
moment là alors je sais pas si c'est lui
qui a monté le coup mais dans le
restaurant est quelqu'un qui vient lui
demander un autographe
vu ce qui n'a pas monté le coup révisé
moi mais à chaque fois il ya à chaque
fois qu'on sort dans un restaurant et il
ya au moins une personne qui dit en bon
jour mais solidaire je voulais te lèves
et chaque fois que vous êtes en restant
il a prévu qu'il ya un maquis dans la
rue à une époque c'était disait-on alors
c'est ce soir là le soir du restaurant
banques
il ya eu pénétration
cette fois c'est que tu es pressé quand
même je sais qu'on va
c'est la main dans la main au temps pour
moi un prémice je ne m'y attendais pas
et le premier baiser à voile a quand
même ses premiers baisers la palud l'on
m'a dit tout à l'heure c'est la femme
qui m'a sauvé la vie
oui et ça je vais vous dire si une forme
d' une phrase qu'on ne dit pas souvent
non c'est vrai oui et bien sûr et lyon
voilà donc la baise c'est à disneyland
s'élance de la pole mais c'était de la
neige connaît pas ça laisse moi le world
non c'est à dire que l'on pourrait tout
à fait honnête pour être tout à fait
honnête vous avez imposé à apple ou un
délai assez long à la 20 minute
non ça a duré entre votre première
rencontre est distendu s'est passé
combien de temps eva cinq mois c'est à
quoi moi à moi mon un mois par la dce
landes de paris
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs ils vont passer par bordeaux
si vous n'êtes pas une fille facile
parce que y en a qu à grandcamp est
couchée au parc astérix à temps et va
dit moi je veux bien aller à disneyland
avec toi même tu sais quoi
à condition qu'on ait deux chambres
séparées par une sorte de bonnes
longueurs ce qu'il a fait il a vraie
légende du communiqué
voilà la jeunesse est à ses yeux pour
regarder la tv ou encore je suis arrivé
je sais pas c'est comme ça que jamais
jamais quand même là tenu sa parole
on a deux chambres séparées ensuite donc
ensuite c'est le climax de la faire
c'est la préparation c'est vous prenez
une douche sans des psy vous mettez du
boom du parfum une nuisette vaporeuse
nazis ne vais pas vous expliquer ce
qu'on lisait de vaporeuses dieu sait si
vous en étiez à vis des musiques
d'amoureuse est alors y'a un truc j'ai
pas bien compris dans le bouquin est ce
que vous pensez les tétons pour qu'ils
durcissent sa queue en me préparant je
me suis souvenu d'une scène du film où
il ya cinq mannequins qui vendent en une
soirée ce parti que ton s enfin certains
endroits des records est la face à
allumer les phares
et je ne l'a pas fait ah ben là vous
êtes à fait non et vous vous êtes super
inquiète quand vous arrivez dans la
chambre de votre mii êtes vous fait
super bien parfumée vous dites va-t-il
aimé mon corps tous phares éteints
oui j'ai demandé si vous n'en verrez que
vous êtes une abnégation extraordinaire
parce que je faisais à votre place je me
serais dit est-ce que je vais mais le
sien et vous
c'est vrai que par un peu d'histoire et
puis ça qui vient les belles comme vous
êtes magnifique je vous en prie vous
êtes là pour ça alors quand une femme
est vraiment amoureuse d'un angle elle
pense pas est ce que lui il va être un
bon amant est-ce que lui il va me plaire
parce que il vous plaît déjà voilà bravo
et là ce soir là dans cette petite
chambre de disneyland
vous lui fait découvrir une eva
sensuelles voire un peu indécente
certains moments space mountain manette
eca en tous les cas eva dit quand même
c'est quand même important
elle dit paul luu a été le meilleur
amant que je n'ai jamais eu à disneyland
valeur ajoutée au parent est là alors
après évidemment il ya le revers de la
médaille est oui toujours
c'est le matin le réveil vous découvrez
l'homme public si vous découvrez que
paul loup par exemple il va
l'anniversaire d'yves rénier il va dans
les langues commissaire moulin
ouais si c'est vrai c'est donc qu'elle
ait aussi les ragots évidemment on
pourra vous n'écrit pas ses livres est
trop maigre
les gens sont très ou non étaient
impliqués dans des affaires de trafic
d'armes enfin voilà tous les rumeurs
comme il s'en fout il ya des rumeurs
aussi il faut bien le dire d'ailleurs on
dit tu une fille de l'est
voilà ça le vent là les gens sont pleins
oui c'est vrai que ça m'a fait de la
peine en france que qui est comme un
pays pas mal avec beaucoup de couture
tout ça alors que c'est aussi un pays
qui a un peu trop de préjugés et aussi
vers l'agent venant de la saison passée
au début je le prenais très mal
maintenant je vais prend avec un peu
plus de compréhension juste d'humour un
peu plus du mois donc tout se passe bien
yahia au coeur dit il ya aucun problème
paul houde vue trompera pas parce qu'ils
étaient pas nous y sur plan sexuel dont
il n'a aucune raison de vous tromper
c'est pas nadine qui va me me contredire
sur ce point mais écoutez si un homme
est un homme qui aime les femmes
de toute façon qu'elles soient belles
qu'elles soient jeunes qu'elle soit
c'est une autre qu'il veut toujours j'ai
un avis un peu différent sur ça pour
dire que la femme avec laquelle il est
si elle lui fait rêver sur un point où
beaucoup de points même si l'idée de
latran père va lui venir à l'esprit il
va pas le faire il va passer branche là
dessus parce que les 11100 pas excusez
moi le chien juin non quand même un peu
écouté des îles aucune peur vous est
absolument divine
ils ne voudront pas jamais boire voilà
voilà bien si vous êtes pour nadine
taper sms
si vous êtes tour eva eva en fait notre
fusion
la conclusion des canaris va gicler
tranquille
c'est une histoire d'amour entre un
homme blessé et est une femme déçue
c'est une bien belle histoire d'amour en
plus si vous avez écrit une chanson oh
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
[Applaudissements]
m
quand il est mort
un petit bec mais je vais te dire un
truc marrant tu es tu es trop bronzé la
des champions de tout ça mais là ça fait
le manque à gagner de la thune et qui
peut aller ça fait quarante n 1 et
vacances à tous et reste bloqué dans
l'habitacle c'est pas des vacances je ne
suis pas du genre à laisser des vacances
suis allé cacher de l'argent et tu as
beaucoup d'argent non vous étiez en
train de dire qu'un homme trompé
toujours une femme oui et pas toujours
mais souvent enfin nadine moi si on
était ensemble
non
toujours paiement
je peux pas ouais ben franchement là je
vais dire c'est un peu trop bien voir
avec tes yeux comme si au milieu on
dirait des phares allumés les vacances
après la coupe du monde messieurs
[Applaudissements]
vous trouvez pas que c'est trop bronzé
ça franchement est-ce que ça se fait
d'arriver à un dîner trop bronzé non et
enfin on va écouter la chanson que paul
loup ça fait quand il a écrit il a écrit
les paroles
je ne savais pas
la carrière
alors oui
stéphane corre jean louis dont il est
inutile ici de rappeler la carrière dite
moi une question que tout le monde se
pose et va vous l'avez écrit tout seul
votre livre oui allez comme grande fille
c'est bien donc donc il
paul loup il vous a dit qu'il était
ruiné donc vous l'aimez pour son
physique alors pour ce qui les entoure
pour ce qu'il a en tout six et qui
comprit il a pas un peu regrossi 7 ans
ou non non non non au contraire au
contraire il perdu par savez pour moi
c'est le physique c'est pas ce qui
compte le plus à une chose c'est ce
banal de dire ça mais c'est quand même
bien vous avez discuté un peu avec ses
ex pour savoir où vous mettez les pieds
non non je connais pas siècle ohlala
mais il m'en a pas le même temps vous
êtes en france depuis
je n'ai pas de suite mais ça va faire
face et avec des gars on n'a pas parlé
de ça dites moi une question je suis
désolé mais bon vous pouvez vous boucher
les oreilles les enfants là s'il vous
plaît dites moi il prend des viagra vous
croyez incertaine en avant les moyens
d'en avoir bien bah écoutez je crois
qu'on a fait le tour de l'or il y avait
plein de questions à poser
quoi par exemple ce qu'il est un [ __ ]
pour faire l'amour
il est là bon le faire entrer non oui je
suis leader
[Applaudissements]
bonobo soir je crois que vous avez
trouvé ça louche solidaire votre
meilleur agent de publicité
ah non c'est tout autre chose ah bon
elle est déjà au moins votre meilleur
agent de publicité parce que c'est
vraiment elle vous défend en quoi qu'on
lui disait l'extraordinaire défend pas
je dis ce que je pense à tous ouais
c'est une fille formidable il m'a sauvé
la vie
oui j'ai failli mourir tout allait mal
j'étais noir jaune du bosc
alors quoi comme de votre puce était
plutôt positif c'est incroyable tous les
cas nadine on peut que se féliciter de
voir ce ce jeune couple dans autant de
féliciter non mais je pense que le où tu
as beaucoup de chance et elle a surtout
beaucoup de chance de faire son
éducation par un monsieur qui quand même
a une grande expérience ça n'est pas
vous gallopin qui pourriez la nuit
d'halloween
à la loupe
mayrand
ouah
[Applaudissements]
qui
d'un côté et paul loup est devant on va
vous laisser filer parce que vous avez
sûrement beaucoup de choses à faire et
va nous a expliqué vous étiez quand paul
où le meilleur amant qu'elle n'ait
jamais eue
moi j'ai rien dire elle mais elle l'a
dit c'est vrai que cela dit oui bon je
peux le redire encore le redire voilà
c'est le maire avant que jamais merci
il retourne à disneyland et walt disney
ils ont la grande parade dans 20 minutes
et sans labour
ils vont me qu'est chaque année
maintenant nadine de rothschild
non maintenant
je m'appelle hélène
je suis
dorothée
voici l'un de fougerolles
[Musique]
c'est quand même la soirée des jolies
donzelles c1 ce soir quand même là
vraiment c'est comme on aime toujours le
bon soir comment varrault mines est très
bien et sa chatte
bah oui alors plus avait déclaré le
tournage c'est le meilleur moment
la promotion c'est un autre métier que
l'on passe chez ardisson ou que l'on
fasse une avant-première à trifouillis
les oies moi vous aimez pas la promotion
vous êtes bien j'aime bien rodée sont
surtout je fais surtout que ça mais
c'est vrai que j'aime bien je commence à
me faire mais il faut être faut s'en
[ __ ] en fait façon le film il est fait
je vais vous dire non mais sérieux c'est
énorme ça fait l'ouverture de cannes
toute façon je n'ai pas de problème mais
je me casse allemands restent alors on
va essayer de faire ça proprement 1
donc vous êtes la marquise de pompadour
hélène de fougerolles dans fanfan la
tulipe de gérard krawczyk en lui il a
vraiment un nom pour un mec scrabble tu
es un peu paumé s'apitoyait lui dit
gérard krawczyk
donc voila et donc dans le film ya
vincent perez penelope cruz didier
bourdon michel muller et vous alors le
film fait donc l'ouverture du festival
de cannes le 14 mai et il sort le même
soir dans toute la france donc voilà
donc ça a été impliqué ça va être énorme
sort le même jour curling du bonheur
j'ai mal an
qu'est ce qu'on fait regardez la bande
annonce non allons-y manito dit serge
garde connaît
les effectifs 46 1962 à 6000 combien
960t pas vraiment vous dire tout ça
trente sept mille seul vous fait
tranquille volontaire à trouver d'ici
demain d'abord les noms fanfan enfants
comment je les ignore
une seule et dernière place êtes vous
disposé à prendre lisant on pourrait
pour les élections comme celle que je
n'épouse pas genève où jamais il
l'épousera après la guerre c'est la
guerre de sept ans déjà quatre de passer
le plus gros est fait comme yazid au
bout c'est un vin d'une banda kalinic
s'il vous plaît j'aime pas à vos
oreilles et vos manières l'écorché tu
n'aime rien ici émasculé ah non ça c'est
trop en tout cas épargné la nuque
on frappe monsieur fin à mon attention
madame
joker leur avais me plaît beaucoup
bonjour charmant abeilles c'est le coeur
n'est ni rien ôter cette date 1
les purs kono d'une source libre comme
l'air
enfin tout court devient trop natif
voilà pendant la tulipe de gyor car avec
ma santé
[Applaudissements]
douce et muller alors à un moment
effectivement l'histoire donc à un
moment vous traversez un bois vous êtes
avec henriette fille du roi et les
brigands attaque le carrosse mes enfants
intervient c'est la fanfare latine et un
futur alors c'est la réussite pour vous
ah bon bah oui est ce que vous vous
croyez comme vous étiez jeune est ce que
vous croyez aussi endurante n'ont
maintenant plus je me trouve pas du tout
courageuse pas du tout si vous êtes une
endurance totalinfo croix voici la
preuve si vous êtes là bas moi j'ai pas
trop le choix en même temps je sais rien
faire d'autre
non je suis pas négatif surréaliste non
non c'est vrai jeu bah oui je continue
mais j'ai pas trop le jeu super de
comprendre votre marine n'est pas
milliardaires mr2 des tourneurs
fraiseurs trésor wii va bien non moi je
trouve très endurante parce que quand on
quand on pense au handicap que vous
aviez vous aviez dans la vie au départ
d'abord des gens vous confondez avec
qu'elle joue donc ça c'était déjà
terrible la région c'est celle qui suce
non on sent qu'elle bonbons d'abord vous
appelez hélène rig one de fougerolles
victoire quand tu t'appelles comme ça
déjà c'est pas séparé de ses parents
sont des aristos mais fauché donc tu as
déjà le début un petit peu difficile à
l'école vous être à chaud un peu gourde
icha faut dire aux chercheurs de
gourdins
beau thème astral et justement je montre
comment tous ces handicaps n'ont pas
empêché hélène d'y arriver à d'ailleurs
vous êtes snobé comme seul à new york
par les élèves d'ulis traces berg
institute
vous avez que noémie dit elle est aussi
belle et il n'y a pas longtemps l'a
appris à jouer nous imitent a vu tout à
l'heure quand elle a fait la colère là
j'ai bien fait là quand nos amis à fait
la colère j'étais ça c'est lee strasberg
ouais ok après bon bah c'est les années
galères il ya la pub aubisque rock qui
la publie ce rock et la sitcom
effectivement le collège des coeurs
brisés ou vous appeler mme maryse qui
fait qu'appeler tout le monde après anne
marie pendant pendant des années
évidemment et puis le film porno je sais
je savais vous anime en parlait souvent
mes fans je bouffe voilà qu'à m'en mords
faire des choix et enfin quand même non
c'est un film par dose de tout à fait
honnête c'est un film porno de quoi
enfants j'ai fait la bande son vous êtes
gonflés à c'est vrai que j'ai déconné
mais sa maman moi je suis vous aider
exemple c'était le truc c'est à tapotage
les vacances au cap d'agde voilà comment
met on en parle pas non non pas photo
moi j'espère les vacances au cap d'agde
vous dès qu'on en parle sinon oui je
suis prêt sur un film avec un très très
très très un photographe très très très
connue mondialement qui me prend pour un
film qui va réaliser
donc je tairai le nom du monsieur et
donc on allait tout paris a fait le
casting est tout et je me retrouve il
nous dit on va vous venez nous retrouver
au cap d'agde on va commencer à faire
des photos qui serviront pour le film et
tout est là je suis dans le camp de
nudisme le plus grand du
decroix et donc ça trois jours à poil
avec votre capello avait 16 ans et donc
et il était très embêté parce qu'il
aurait fallu que je me suis les poils du
minou voix pour faire que jules et la
voilà c'est ça la scène sous la chine
comme ça doit faire mal et c'est très
loin et lee strasberg n'était pas plus
les bastons mignonne c'est dommage que
vous soyez vraiment la vie est mal faite
tu trouves pas laurent je trouve qu'elle
est très drôle et l extraordinaire qui
l'attend brest avec nous avec plaisir
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici jbeil
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
buffet jeu
blatter de l'ex est l'inventeur d'un
endroit
[Musique]
40 millions de disques vendus jeep est
l'inventeur du rock bonsoir merci
d'abord choisir en parle alors le 27 mai
prochain
jimmy pey'j atlantique va lancer un
triple cd un double dvd de led zep avec
des performances des enregistrements
inédits
donc on va faire deux promos d'abord le
triple cd mais cela
et ensuite le double dvd
[Musique]
voilà ce qui est dans le manitoba 17 10
mille tonnes alors dit me paye si je
voulais résumer votre vie en deux images
je prendrai la première au début des
années 50
le rock'n'roll fait irruption dans votre
vie avec une chanson d'elvis presley qui
s'appelle baby let's play house et c'est
une révélation pour vous la première
fois que vous avez entendu cette chanson
ça vous êtes décidé à vous mettre à la
guitare
yahoo l'est en réalité baby spa où
c'était une phase bêta disques d'elvis
presley et tout d'un coup je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait un mail à la
guitare acoustique
elvis qui qui chantait qui jouait cette
électrique derrière ça faisait tout un
espèce de d'orchestre qui va séduire ses
mains voilà est devenu l'un des plus
grands guitaristes de rock du monde et
la deuxième image est toujours lié elle
vise donc vous allez à las vegas vous
rencontrer elvis presley vous arriver
tous les quatre les quatre led zep un
petit peu intimidé devant lui les gardes
du corps sont sont très nerveux
d'ailleurs il ya un petit peu des
problèmes entre les gardes du corps de
led zep et les gardes du corps d'elvis
presley
vous trouvez en face de lui ou sais pas
trop quoi lui dire et à un moment c'est
john bonham qui rompt le silence en
disant c'est quoi le hot rod que tu
piloter dans l'amour frénétique et là
d'un seul coup tout le monde se met à
parler
la serre ont pu on a parlé de la musique
des premiers jours puis c'était c'était
un grand départ et voilà et donc deux
fois elvis presley une fois très jeune
et une fois au sommet de votre gloire
alors vous êtes né jimmy page en 1944
dans le middlesex le 9 janvier vous êtes
capricorne comme moi alors d'abord vous
êtes musicien de studio vous jouez avec
les kinks vous jouez sur you really got
me
des kings ensuite vous jouez avec joe
cocker dans my friends vous jouez avec
donovan vous jouez avec les ou donc
d'abord musicien de studio et puis à la
période des yardbirds alors là c'est une
grande une grande période dans le groupe
des yardbirds avec jeff beck didier les
yarber
oui
[Musique]
oh
poolers
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est leur board
[Applaudissements]
fumer
disait que j'étais un requin de studio
je jouais avec ces groupes assez
prestigieux y compris d'ailleurs destin
française comme johnny hallyday michel
polnareff également et beaucoup d'autres
mais alors il y avait une star qui était
ici ce soir
françoise à wright et j'ai joué sur un
de ses albums mais il pouvait pas le
savoir parce que moi j'étais qu'un gamin
qui fait la guitare dans le studio et
airs ce serait peut-être une surprise
pour elle de savoir que je suis devenu
ensuite ça va connaître son incroyable
alors les meilleurs buzz après les new
york burns qui ont été rebaptisés led
zeppelin par keith moon le batteur des
who
parce qu'il avait une phrase il dit j'ai
toujours hugo over like led zepplin
comme un faiseur plein en plomb c'est ça
c'était sa phrase tu as trahi dites est
exact c'est un peu un jeu de mots alors
le groupe led zeppelin a été fondée
pendant l'été 1968 avec jimmy page
robert plant john van hamme et john paul
jones soit vraiment énorme ici
c'est eux qui ont inventé le var de
féminin 21 heures didier darcel aussi
[Musique]
allez
oui
d
[Musique]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
quoi
ça
à
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
voilà tu me payes mai
elle dîner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tous les cas merci de tout le bonheur
que nous avait donné merci depuis le
groupe s'est arrêté à la mort de john
bonham vous avez décidé carrément de se
quitter le groupe
il ya absolue oui parce que le secret de
led zeppelin le secret de son succès sur
toulouse c'est que chaque concert était
différente un jour alors qu il y avait
énormément de l'improvisation et à la
mort de john n'y avait pas d'autre
conclusion possible que la dissolution
du groupe parce que même avec les
meilleures intentions du monde des gens
venaient me voir at elle des batteurs
qui pourrait le remplacer mais en
réalité ça n'aurait pas été honnête
parce que le rôle la contribution de
john bonham à 10 ans un couple qui
pensait ces pseudos batteur aussi bien
que john badham c'est à dire que je les
aide la grosse caisse comme des
castagnettes cp1
c'est un génie de la batterie
d'emballage fait on entend alors les zep
baigné dans une atmosphère un petit peu
cette année est un petit peu
luciférienne on a parlé de magie noire
on a parlé d'un signe nazi
vous étiez branche éparses à l'époque
disons que je m'intéressais au
mysticisme et vous dire que ce qui
m'intéressait surtout c'était quand même
led zeppelin c'est quand même mon nom
pain quotidien et je buvais je mange est
une épine du matin au soir
c'est tout ça qui m'amusait alors vous
êtes un grand admirateur d'un dénommé
aleister crowley grand magicien ou
escroc notoire d'ailleurs les avis sont
très partagés sur lui c'est vrai qu'au
mexique c'est alistair crowley a réussi
à faire disparaître son reflet dans un
miroir
c'est au courant de cette histoire
toutes sortes anecdote au sujet de ce
monsieur mais en fait ce qu'il est en
train de dire à son époque c'est que
avec la volonté on arrive à tous et
c'est également l'égalité des sexes qui
le qu'il préconisait de visionnaire
absolument en avance sur son temps et
j'ai vu ces ouvrages mais j'ai également
d'autres auteurs on n'avait pas cueillir
ce n'est pas la motivation principale
non mais vous avez tout acheter sur le
mystère que vous avez acheté tous les
livres tous les objets vous pouviez
acheter
et vous avez même acheté sa maison à lui
qu'est sur le loch ness non c'est
vraiment facile si vous aviez pu sa
maison vous n'auriez également acheté
était très belle justaucorps du lac du
loch ness
c'était absolument spectacle magnifique
vite qu'il a inventé la libération
totale de l'individu c'est probablement
là sa contribution principale en effet
nous est ce que vous avez pris beaucoup
de drogue à l'époque de led zep je vais
peut-être appris autant que qu'on a pu
le croire oui apparemment oui parce
qu'il a une bonne mine quand il a
pratiquement 60 ans et qu'elle est
l'hôtel où vous avez cassé le plus de
meubles et de plus de chambres à titre
d'exemple qui a été découpée avec un
épée de samouraï à sabres est quelqu un
qui s est rentré à l'hôtel
à travers tokyo tune l'humain dans la
rue abbé toumodi et très polis par
rapport à tout ça on était des vilains
garçons à l'école un petit peu mélodieux
et notre gueule cathédrale c'est quelque
chose
est ce que vous croyez que non les morts
c'est sa rock'n'roll
moi je dirais que c'était c'était une
forme d'hédonisme cette façon de dire
c'est quoi la question si non à la
question suivante c'est une interview
vous êtes en france jimmy page
donc on va faire une interview fromage
ou dessert
[Musique]
est ce que vous préférez des stones sous
lés beatles sont intéressantes parce que
les beatles à leurs débuts je n'ai pas
pris très au sérieux
il faisait des chansons comprises mais
c'est un homme à terre un premier album
ça m'a pas beaucoup frappe mais ça va
pas interpellé dix ans mais quand ils
ont commencé à faire blue jam one the
les prix beaucoup plus au sérieux
et quand ils ont enregistré sa durée
quelques années seulement il est certain
que les beatles on développe se sont
développées de manière absolument
phénoménale
c'est une force de la nature en poste
alors que les rolling stones pour moi je
les ai toujours adoré parce que il
venait en fait et même origine qu'eux
mais c'est à dire le plus newser malibu
comme ça est ce que vous préférez mick
jagger keith richards
je peux parler à qui va avec
d'accord est ce que vous préférez john
lennon et paul mccartney
probablement au john h
non john allen à coup sûr même alors est
ce que vous préférez que vos enfants se
droguent ou qu'ils écoutent britney
spears écoutez prêter spears is à peu
une drogue surtout si on est un peu
obsédé par elle et les solutions dans
les spas le disque on le fait on le
passe en boucle mais mes enfants
et il adore enfin il se drogue à l'air à
dakar très bien est ce que vous préférez
quand pirates vos albums ou que plus
personne ne les écoute
en vérité avec led zeppelin
il y avait des cassettes à l'époque à 7
et à cette référence tous les soirs
hénin il y avait une partie a été
échantillonnée qui arrivait chez et puis
il ya une période malheureuse de
l'imaginer j'ai essentiellement divorce
et j'ai quitté la maison et qui est des
gens qui disent qu'ils se sont acoquinés
avec mon ex femme et à ce titre ils ont
cliqué en fait tous ces échantillons
s'étaient tous les concerts qui a monté
à des années des années jusqu'à 1980 et
également des enregistrements de
répétition de tout alors si vous pensez
à un viol musicale - une espèce de
drogue
là vous avez un bel exemple mais c'était
malheureux et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y avait tellement de bons
piratage parce qu'ils avaient des des
bandes maîtresses
est-ce que vous préférez la première
guerre en irak où la deuxième j'ai pas
de préférence grande ville ou pour
l'autre
est ce que vous préférez une bonne
bouffe ou une baisse moyenne which is te
bouffe de baisse se serait toujours un
banquet pour moi dacca
jimmy est ce que vous préférez votre
femme ou votre maîtresse c'est la
guitare mais est ce vraiment une réponse
merci
merci thank you
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
vive les mineurs condamnés
[Musique]
m
maintenant jean françois bizot
[Musique]
bonsoir
jean françois bizot ça fait du bien du
mille-pattes sinon jean-françois waysand
cheffe du bien parce que en fait il faut
savoir que le premier concert en france
jimmy page
c'était à une soirée de la chaussée et
alors c'était une époque où des soins
des chaussées t'avais les mecs en
smoking qui tu avais un peu pressés des
appareils et une chemise blanche
1 et puis les filles en robes longues 1
et puis deux mecs qui étaient en bas
d'un pilier en béton un jeu toujours
c'est vrai on a un pied en béton ou
jouer les épines parise et trois câbles
un ampli de fortune et jouets en bois la
pierre mais tout ça intéressait
strictement personne c'est direct les
viols les violences trouve qu'il est
encore en blonde
ouais passé ici oui bah non il comprend
les bois un bon semble être de plus en
plus ça joshi scott en vieillissant jean
françois bizot jean françois bizot vous
êtes journalistes patrons de presse
fondateur d'actuels de nova de radio
nova
vous êtes écrivain il ya les déclassés
qui ressort en ce moment
[Musique]
et puis les années blanches donc tous
les deux chez grasset voilà et vous
publiez actuellement un livre qui
s'appelle un moment de faiblesse
[Musique]
alors serait dû s'appeler même pas mal
et pourtant ça fait mal puisque jean
françois bizot vous racontez votre
cancer un cancer de la vessie
je vous dit je sais pas si c'est mon
plus grand reportage
mais c'est mon plus long reportage bah
oui parce qu'il est pas finie et que en
fait on apprend dans cette aventure
on apprend une patience dont on ne peut
pas vous prévenir
on peux pas vous dire il va falloir être
patient parce que c'est décourageant
donc on vous dit oued en trois mois tu
vas voir il ya provoqué europe un petit
trois mois de plus au fait y en a
rajouté une couche on va te greffe était
propre aux cellules ça va être
intéressant
il s'agit d'ailleurs vous dites
d'ailleurs le patient est impatient par
définition
alors on parle de reportages moi je
crois que c'est surtout de la
littérature je vais dire le début du
vitrage g barbouillé des dizaines de
céramique blanche du g2 mon pinceau
rupestres carmin vermillon fuchsia rose
pivoine rouge brun chaque pigments
afficher une consistance appartenant à
une peinture différentes mais jamais le
même rouge vous dit le rouge c'est
rothko moi je comparerais le bouquin au
tableau de munch qui s'appelle le cri ou
un tableau de bacon tu vois c'est c'est
comme ça c'est un peu comme ça ce
bouquin on m'a dit ben il est tout nu
sans être à poil
1 donc c'est une trace écrite il est
venu sans être un poil donc tu peux le
publier 1 parce que en fait parce qu'en
fait le lob
on bascule du jour au lendemain dans une
autre société c'est-à-dire vous qui
connaissez le clubbing
d'un seul coup on a le vip pass gold de
la nouvelle société qui s'appelle le
cancer club
c'est une maladie qu'on pourrait miner
si vous vouliez je pourrai pour ému mais
ça veut dire c'est une manie comme ça
hein
et ça c'est de trois heures par jour
pendant un certain temps
c'est une maladie comme ça après des
injections de cantegril c'est une
maladie comme ça ouais quand on a mal
ouais et ça fait mal ah ouais alors on
dit on fait ça on a pas mal d'ailleurs
alors on pas au début si la découverte
du mal justement des taches de sang sur
des toilettes verte
ça se passe en inde alors les deux
solutions soit c'est la bilharziose un
qui est une maladie qu'on peut choper
dans les pays exotiques c'est des
petites amies barils soit ce char qu'ils
soient si le cancer est en fait
malheureusement le diagnostic
c'est le cancer vous revenez à paris
vous passer sur le billard le
chirurgiens retirent dites-vous une
tumeur de la taille d'un d'un quart d'un
paquet de dénis la traduire 308 balles
de tact pour un traitement que vous sous
forme ils valent que vous la l'attraper
en finir ce concert blé d'attraper en
fumant je pense que c'est un cancer qui
présente l'inconvénient de ne pas être
déclarés sur le paquet de clopes donc
aux photographes
on ne surveille pas là-dessus et c'est
pas les poumons c'est la vessie alors
évidemment le chirurgien vous au père et
puis après vous dis moi j'ai tout raclée
j'ai enlevé le plus possible mais je
suis pas apte il a il arrive que l'herbe
repousse et donc c'est la signaux ne
sais pas c'est pas terrible
c'est la forme atomique la chimio ouais
c'est une guerre il a cédé
du voyage dans le monde de la douleur
puisque peas et devient un calvaire à ce
moment là les plaisirs oui c'est un peu
dire qu'il vit un calvaire c'est chiant
voilà les limaces géantes c'est quoi les
limaces et hantent les humains les
limaces gens c'est un truc qui se passe
quand on a été opéré de cette partie du
corps où ils appellent ça des c'est
ainsi que très souvent ce cd chute
d'escale de même ça et en fait c'est
quand même pour les mecs comme nous un
truc assez curieux à observer quoi parce
que en fait on se retrouve là c'est
bouché donc un plaisir de la douleur et
puis il faut expulser un truc qui passe
pas un conduit qui n'a pas été prévu
main à la bonne taille plutôt avec l'as
tu vois tu vas chain le petit tuyau là
comme ça et puis pouf hilson linas une
limace
oui bon bah on va dire les choses comme
elles sont c'est super bowl en quelque
chose dans les hôpitaux les mecs aux
narines ils ont lieu à la cantine est ou
non mais c'est une histoire dont l'un
très difficile avec ce passé sa journée
et sort un truc qui fait très mal
voilà ça fait mal à chaque fois et
pupilles en avoir 50 ans faisait
l'habitant charpy il faut dire là faut
dire les choses avaient une sonde dans
le canal de l'urètre et alors il ya une
règle c'est gore il ya une scène dans
votre bouquin ce que le rock terrible
c'est un soir voulu rennais un soir vous
voulez vous hurlez alors les médecins
viennent les infirmières bien ils
voulaient sur les pendant des heures
vous dites je vote nazis à ce moment là
je vous dis pas ce que je ferais un
chiotte un jeu prononcer le nom d'un
homme politique menu
qui porte un nom vaguement bretons eux
ce halo 1
c'était ça m'aidait votre façon de vous
défouler d'ailleurs je découverte
finalement que d'un des meilleurs
combats contre la douleur
c'est de manifester donc c'est de
prendre le nom du médecin tuto retard
mis par exemple ce prince vers vous avec
la nature comme ça pour m
malgré tout petit mois je peux rien j'ai
pas été doté par la nature et donc il a
avec 1 et bien il faut manifester parce
que quand on manifeste ça mobilise le
cerveau donc on prend les médecins sur
une tombe du bon en fait du bon
pédophile du [ __ ] dupont un pédophile
c'est de jouer quatre fois le comprendre
ouais ils voulaient sur les comme ça
pendant tout l'été mais non ils ne
peuvent rien non à un moment ils
s'aperçoivent que la sonde est trop
gonflé mais ils peuvent rien il se
dégage de cette situation ils sont trois
pour 25 personnes
ça va pas ce [ __ ] ils sont trois pour
25 personnes et chaque chambre
chaque endroit c'est 10 à 15 minutes de
soins ouais donc tu sonnes et il faut
oser le temps d'arriver et puis avec son
état pire que toi toi tu as eu juste mal
mais les autres mois pour leur changer à
20 minutes faits mais voilà alors
évidemment là vous vous donner des
détails qui sont malheureusement vrai
quoi c'est à dire qu'à ce moment-là
terre le prépuce extrêmement bon flée le
gland marbré et alors il ya un mélange
comme ça sous le prépuce de 2,2 de crem
a les opportunistes a eu les
opportunités des maladies opportunistes
faisait des champignons par exemple et
et vous dites je n'avais jamais vécu en
tête à tête
un spectacle personnel aussi navrant
c'est à dire que vous êtes navré en fait
de voir l'état de votre sexe c'est vrai
que je suis la vraie parce que je peux
pas le montrer en plus donc
déjà ça c'est navrant vont servir
donc ça c'est navrant je me demande ce
que tu as et après donc je sors mr bah
moi je vous rassure
et puis et vous dit jean-françois la
baise est impossible dit sans fard
écroulé alexandre y perdit son pouvoir
vos ardeurs des quenouilles ouais vous
n'avez plus droit à l'alcool maintenant
bah non je vais rien empêché way la
drogue n'ont rien empêché train partie
du deal with an livre d'ailleurs
j'assume mais j'assume très très
fortement le cannabis thérapeutique
ouais que j'avais quitté pendant dix ans
également vous dit le cannabis est
devenue un tic donc j'arrête et puis
vous reprenez pour des raisons
thérapeutiques
ouais je peux dire pourquoi un l'ayant
vécu ça m'a beaucoup surpris j'y croyais
pas mais je croyais pas pour certains un
peu de tout nous est déjà fait ce choix
est en fait aplanissait
les sautes d'humeur les produits sur
actions violent et sa reconstruisait
l'appétit par contre et 3 juin dans
toutes les drogues qu'on m'a fait
prendre
parce que finalement dans cette maladie
on ne fait prendre toutes les drogues
possibles imaginables qui ont que dont
aucune n'a une fois fin de plaisir ce
qui est chiant d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il
fallait publier ce bouquin on m'a dit
oui on m'a dit oui on m'a dit ça donne
la pêche
ouais alors je vais faire bon et puis
ça fait bizarre parce que c'est je
ressens ce truc comme un livre écrit par
un procédé qui l'est pas moins et
comment ça va se passer maintenant
la suite des événements terminés ou
terminés c'est tous les jours et encore
de la chimio à venir vous la chimio
c'est que c'est que la chimio c'est
variable pour les gens il ya dans le
chimio il ya
le truc qui est chiant c'est de
l'imprévisibilité de doublement on va
être annulé
on est un il est tout d'un coup et
on n'est plus rien ouais on tient un
journal à la main là comme ça le tour de
la chaudière journal
c'est facile à lire journal libération
bon un truc pas prise de tête du tout
quoi bon puis tombe
j'en dis merde il est tombé non peut
rien faire donc ça c'est un cheminot
aimer le le truc le plus marrant truc
marrant parce que je pense que ça va
c'est quand même été cloué comme ça tu
vois un genre jésus christ enfin ton
tour
donc tu aies joué parce que on te prends
ton sens de la la 1 on le fait circuler
pour préparer des nouvelles cellules de
toi même plutôt clonés parce que c'est
un traitement hyper moderne qui va très
bien et ont été adoptés cru comme ça
pendant cette heure je peux pas bouger
du tout c'est chiant mais qu'est-ce qui
fait chier quand on peut pas bouger très
bien joué voilà un vrai mec tu connais
la vie et alors tu peux pas de gratter
évidemment tu t'aperçois souvent là
pendant sept heures du nombre de fois où
tu as envie de te gratter c'est
invraisemblable fugace à lui tout et tu
cries venir gratter non et alors là il
se passe un truc absolument terrible
c'est que les autres ne savent pas te
gratter ça peut être une si tu te dis ça
va donner
elle prétend avoir été choisie est
tellement tendue n'est que tu sens plus
rien pendant un moment un audit e crac
comme ça et ça c'est terrible
nadine vous avez connu ce genre de
maladie j'imagine oui avec mon mari mais
votre mari mais c'est pourquoi il
n'avait pas de cancer il avait tous les
problèmes que vous avez décrit en partie
il n'avait pas de cancer mais il avait
de l'emphysème ce qui tu m'as être un
site très très difficile à gérer et
mais été d'un courage comme vous
monsieur extraordinaire ça en public et
puis la lâcheté c'est dans les chiottes
jean françois bizot
et chez grasset mail à mes yeux
jean françois gillet sel et vous couchez
merci en tous les cas d'avoir été avec
nous courage
bon ça va c'est déjà pas si je suis
redevenu a lâché je peux m'en aller
et maintenant au
vinci christine à bord johnson
d'ici là bon soir bon sang quand vous
parlez français j'espère que vous allez
continuer mais toute façon alors vous
avez été aux usa productrice de
plusieurs émissions de télévision
d'information dont newstand sur cnn et
si bien ce report sur cbs et vous avez
obtenu de nombreux prix de nombreux emmy
awards pour votre travail dont certains
avec le célèbre dan rather voilà et puis
un jour on vous demande d'enquêté sur le
vol 800 twh
vous subissez beaucoup de pression une
campagne de dénigrement et vous serez
même à la sortie licenciés voilà
aujourd'hui vous publiez un livre
christina où vous raconter cette
histoire et où quatorze autres
journalistes américains racontent la
leur ils racontent un peu tous la mort
du journalisme aux états unis d'une
certaine façon
[Musique]
voilà ça s'appelle black list 15 grands
journalistes américains brise la loi du
silence et c'est publié aux éditions les
arènes
alors tout ce sont des journalistes qui
ont eu à enquêter sur des sujets mettant
en cause l'état ou des grandes
entreprises et ils ont finit un jour par
expérimenté ce que vous appelez la
broyeuse
c'est à dire la machine à réduire au
silence alors d'abord parler de vous
christina donc la sphère du vol tbw à
800 l'avion explose en vol le 17 juillet
96 au large de langue island alors la
thèse officielle c'est que l'appareil
était défectueux explosion du réservoir
central vous vous enquêtez et vous
trouvez un certain nombre de preuves qui
démontrent que finalement c'est pas du
tout l'appareil qui était défectueux
mais que l'avion a été atteint par un
missile parce que dans la zone où cet
avion volé il y avait des manoeuvres de
l'armée américaine c'est ça mais je ne
je ne m'accroche pas sur la thèse
missiles ce que j'ai pu faire parce que
à chaque fois que j'ai essayé de faire
est là qu une enquête pour une grande
chaîne ils m'ont firme et lanquais avant
que j'ai pu finir alors ce que j'ai pu
documenter c'était que le gouvernement
tu es sûre et des évidences de 2 d'un
explosif des explosifs qu'il y avait à
l'extérieur et à l'intérieur vous avez
découvert que le résidu rouge qui a été
trouvé sur certains sièges de l'avion
correspond aux carburants d'une fusée
donc d'un missile encore il y avait un
autre journaliste indépendant qui avait
cette évidence et il a fait une analyse
et il y là il a monté son analyse à des
experts ils ont dit oui maintien c'est
du combustible solide pour diffuser mais
il était petit il faisait il n'avait pas
de roseaux alors il m'a donné un peu
aussi pour faire le même annales
et pour faire le même enquête et deux
jours après que j'ai reçu sept morceaux
de résidus le fbi a et à vue ils ont
pris à 6 bias ils ont pris et trois
semaines après bon j'ai perdu mon
travail
voilà l'histoire c'est incroyable c'est
à dire qui viennent devant ils disent
que c'est de la colle 10 original le
résidu rousset de la colle après ils
viennent chez si bien s'ils prennent le
résidu rouge et vous êtes licencié oui
alors vous essayer à ce moment-là à
christina de sortir un livre
mais les éditeurs se désiste tous à
toucher voulait pas toucher
alors on vous accuse et c'est souvent ce
qu'on dit aux gens qui essayent de faire
de l'investigation de chercher un peu la
vérité on vous dit vous êtes une
maniaque du complot ou à la casse et le
mot votre livre dans tous les cas
démontre la fin du journalisme
d'investigation aux etats unis c'est un
petit peu un mythe américain qui
s'écroule pour nous parce que nous pour
nous les journalistes américains voient
la ccvo douars de bernstein c'est des
mecs qui vont au bout ricky qui trouve
la vérité enfin dans tout la firme
américain en vrai ça et finalement quand
on voit votre histoire
et quand on lit les 14 autres
témoignages qui apparaissent dans votre
bouquin on se dit que c'est la fin du
journalisme
joris les morts en fait c'est la fin
enfin j'espère que c'est pas la fin ou
la mort mais quand même et le
journalisme à ce niveau ce niveau très
important parce que ce sont ces
histoires c'est un reportage qui peuvent
changer les choses changer la société
dans une façon par exemple le chapitre
sur kuyt break tard le staff est sûre
l'élection était fait il faut expliquer
à nos amis téléspectateurs c'est que
greg palast démontre que 58 mille
votants ont été rayés des listes
électorales de floride qui est le fief
de jet bush qui est le frère de dubaï ou
et et finalement ça n'a jamais de suite
il est obligé de s'exiler à londres
oui mais justement cette soixante
personnes s'étaient 58 me cette soixante
personnes pourraient faire la différence
en gore et bush alors ce qui a passé
c'est que il a eu il avait l'aide
documents pouvant que ça allait passer
il l'a donné à une productrice à cbs
vous savez ce qu'elle a fait elle a
téléphoné au bureau de djebbour elle a
dit est ce que c'est vrai que vous avez
fait ça est vraiment une on exactement
avec la naïveté de sa part de la candeur
ou est ce que c'est une volonté très
claire pour pour vous dire franchement
elle couvrirait s'est fait ailleurs
exactement c'est ça qu'est les histoires
extraordinaires dans votre bouquin par
exemple que pour soutenir la comptera
sur la contraception car agua les gens
qui luttait contre le régime
démocratiquement élu la cia utilise
l'argent de la drogue est pareil le type
qui a trouvé cette affaire il a été le
type du mercury il a été complètement
blackboulé ans est la plus jeune alice
afin de satisfaire
il est assez surprenant c'est que de
toute façon ces affaires sortent parce
que quand vous parlez de notamment du
nicaragua on le sait mais pourquoi d'une
façon même quand les européens on parle
si tenté que ça ne sorte pas aux états
unis pourquoi quand les européens en
parle ça n'a pas d'impact pour qu'on
puisse ensuite réagir le public
américain ils savent qu'une chose la
télé américaine
c'est comme en france un journal aux
états unis vivent deux cent mille
exemplaires
en dix ans on va on va pas faire une
pâte
j'espère en tous les cas oui alors rien
à faire aussi du lait cancérigènes c'est
à dire que on donne aux vaches des
hormones de croissance
le président à qui est produit par
monsanto qui est un grand laboratoire
évidemment donc à ce moment là qu en
temps quand on veut les attaquer là
dessus en disant votre vote clé est
cancérigène
là c'est pareil quoi il ya tous les gens
sont inquiétés sont soupçonnés
il faut changer ça ça ne peut pas passer
fox a mis la pression sur les
journalistes a falsifié dans un
reportage
ils ont refusé alors ils ont mis ils ont
mis à la porte ils ont fait un procès
contre fax ils ont gagné
425 mille dollars fox a fait un appel et
ils ont gagné la peine sur une
technicalité parce que en effet ils ont
découvert qu' il n'y a pas de loi aux
états unis qui dit que les médias ne
doivent pas n'ont pas permis à mentir au
public
alors maintenant nous avons un président
légal aux états unis où la presse peu
maintien
le public est malheureusement chez nous
le public et ça pas beaucoup on vous dit
qu'on est au début de ce qu'on appelle
la main informations c'est à dire que
pour distraire l'attention des citoyens
pour pas qu'ils s'intéressent l affaire
du vol tbw à 800 ou à l'élection de jet
bouchons ou les cancérigènes et à duch
histoire que vous qui sont dans votre
bouquin de son incroyable sur les suites
de la guerre de corée
les suites de la guerre du vietnam vous
dites que pour distraire l'attention des
citoyens dans leur parle de jay simpson
alors là c'est toute la journée au jay
simpson évidemment au monica lewinsky
c'est à dire quoi ou du bug de l'an 2000
c'est à dire qu'on attire l'attention
des téléspectateurs sur des leurs en
fait surtout outre sur d'autres sujets
le divertissement maintenant ça remplace
le journalisme les plus en plus ce qui
est ce qui a plus important à dire c'est
que pour maintenir une démocratie il
faut pouvoir faire des enquêtes sur ce
niveau
ouais et bien sûr c'est plus possible
alors ce qui est incroyable aussi quand
on lit ce bouquin c'est quand on
constate à quel point la cia jouit aux
états unis d'une immunité incroyable tir
que tout le monde est égal devant la loi
sauf la cia il bénéficie de de
passe-droit absolument incroyable vous
savez je n'aime pas ce que je n'exagère
pas quand je dis que les le cia et comme
un gouvernement en soi mais moins parce
que iso peu importe où sur cette planète
comme comme ils veulent et ce n'est pas
surprenant qui n'a rien à voir pourquoi
vous avez l'action guadeloupéen parce
que je sais moi j'ai vécu mon enfance 1
et il a vu ses drones est un succès
alors ma fille katia vous attend vous
apprendre à le connaître
est-ce que vous avez plus de réceptivité
en france sur ce bouquin aux états unis
ça a déjà bien marché oui ça a bien
mangé et aux etats-unis sur l'internet
et la radio et tous mes collègues sur
les grandes chaînes ils m'ont appelé
pour me
féliciter et tout ça mais il voulait pas
mais vite et sur le programme des
collègues très important de new york
times la même chose mais néanmoins et
avec l'internet et la radio ça s'est
passé il ya un sujet qui n'est pas
traitée dans ce bouquin c'est la guerre
d'irak
alors là il ya eu énormément de deux
mensonges parce que pourquoi cette
guerre alors au début on nous a dit
c'est parce que saddam hussein est lié à
al qaïda après on nous a dit qu'il avait
des armes de destruction massive jamais
trouvé d'ailleurs après on nous a dit
que c'était pour la libération du peuple
irakien qui a l'air bien mal libérer le
malheureux donc là c'est pire que tout
c'est à dire qu'aux états unis on a fait
la guerre sans jamais expliquer aux
citoyens de ce pays quelles étaient les
raisons de la guerre écoutez chaque fois
qu'il change la raison pour laquelle ils
ont fait la guerre le public l'acceptent
c'est ça qui est pour moi c'est ça qui
est vraiment difficile à digérer
et c'est ça c'est pour ça que la mort de
ce type de journalisme aux etats unis
c'est vraiment un danger pour nous le
razer il travaille toujours
oui mais des rien fait la seule chose
qui la fait qui était intéressant après
le 11 septembre il a il a donné une
interview au guardian
et c'est un journal britannique
et oui et il a dit au guardian que howie
qu' on ne pouvait pas faire des enquêtes
important sur le pourquoi et comment de
11 septembre
parce que il y avait l'administration
bush qui kiffent qui menaçait [ __ ] un
journaliste dan houser oui mais il n'a
pas dit ça aux etats unis
mais s'il est grave voyez la patate
dirigeants mais ouais parce que c'est
clair que quand vous faites ce travail
que j'ai fait vos patates un son
disparaissent malheureusement j'ai très
courageuse christina je ne sais pas mais
merci
[Applaudissements]
toi j'ai raison
courageuse bien on va passer au blind
test donc nadine vous restez avec nous
que j'ai beaucoup de chance de gagner
ah oui parce que on va mettre quelqu'un
avec vous qui va vous aider à gagner les
jean sablon il s'appelle pascal sellem
pascal ce que je te confie nadine au
dessus c'est gentil je veux gangan
accord cela dit je te confie nadine
absolument et on passe au blind test ce
soir un blindtest spéciale black music
et aux platines j'appelle mange bien
fait lui peut porter et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
le savent
[Musique]
barbara et nancy vous est absolument
magnifique grand philippe et petit
philippe aussi vous êtes magnifique en
pleine blaxploitation didier attention
c'est maintenant que la boule descendre
alors vous connaissez le principe du
blind test je veux l'interprète nadine
donc ce soir c'est la black music donc
l'interprète ce que des gens qui ont
connu tout à fait bien attention
philippe taffonneau
[Applaudissements]
aretha franklin 2 bien attention arrête
attention là on se concentre c'est très
très grave attention philippe
john barry white dans l'eau
ok
ici c'est pascal qui a vu le premier dit
où il a trouvé attention
à l'époque s'appelait suprême
attention philippe baqué nord de damas
mélanie savoie
22,1 de 2-2-2 schafft sich ab c'est la
misère au dessus pour châtier deux
volets violent baffie voilà attention
philippe
m
personne n'en a
louis thompson
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas il n'est pas le but
à l'aller on
non
nina simone non s'il est validé
[Applaudissements]
embarras à raglan barral agen à chaque
fois qu'ils ont dit une bonne pension
cette émission une nouvelle région
attention s'explique
[Applaudissements]
tâche
dix avocats d'attention yatera nord
à bamako
[Applaudissements]
et ce n'est pas mauvais mais je me suis
inquiet parce qu'on le présentait à
l'époque top 50 est bobby mcferrin
absolument donc ça ah là là j'ai peur de
comprendre le sable et 5 pour qui oui
mais 5pour solo est 8ème
attention une des magazines mais
qu'est-ce-qui finlande réveille toi tu
ris ou fumer la dernière mais nadine
c'est nadine la page où il dirige
l'équipe joue mal c'est une aristo elle
dirige les tic et toi tu trimes mongazon
d'accord
manoir ouais ouais dan warwick
il ya eu pascal ya eu site live sur la
tête de mes enfants ya peu il souffla
jacques gilles a dû au hasard
gérald dionne warwick bien de faire un
disque avec sacha distel noir voilà
c'est un john ware oui donc on est en
baisse voilà attention attention
attention
philippe mexès est maudit c'est dur at
il dit
eh bien on l'a bien vu une chanson de 10
m
thiais
pascal
[Applaudissements]
alors ça nous fait ça nous fait combien
mélina l'équipe de l'an ma fille et
quatre pour l'équipe de nadine c'est pas
mal majin attention philippe la king
cole ou sa demande
chansons interdites aux états unis après
le 11 septembre aux nations unies de la
semaine
c'est là
mais
celle ci
là
c'est pour votre équipe et 5 pour la
leur maintien zaragoza c'est le truc qui
compte à la fin c'est le même temps
d'enfiler
sao paulo
[Applaudissements]
ciao
v
mieux
6 à 7 attention philippe inférieur
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'elle sait champion du monde de
blind test set il a égalisé il ya
énormément pascal ténor c'est nadine qui
m'a soufflé à non mais je suis très
fière
attention là c'est un petit peu plus dur
quand même philippe je sais
e
mother s encore
non
m
tu vas bien 8 attention attention
philippe
automobile mais j'évoque était noir jeu
j'ai deux amours comment s'appelle j'ai
deux amours
joséphine baker non moi le mépris
non
merci oui c'est clair mais citigroup
[Applaudissements]
a huy sont pas elles qui vous est à
égalité magnifique moi je dis qu'on en
reste là bonsoir aromatiques vraiment et
maintenant on va passer aux bons coups
non classés chacun font ça chaque oeil
la gueule chaque solo foules à chacun
pour sa longue
attention c'est très très dur on
commence avec le banco
il me revient
ouais
je
lemay
[Musique]
técher ainsi fait un chat
deux heures tu fais là
ça
cette fonctionnaire quand on me dit que
c'est justement est longue ce banc
caunes ne me suis dit arrête il va
perdre sa maman qui vient de perdre la
garde de ses enfants
c'est une triche du style plus besoin de
l'argent un parce qu'on va garder tes
enfants ça va nous coûter cher ils sont
insupportables
attention fille qui je voudrais annoncer
des investissements énormes week end
[Applaudissements]
l'école a loué
lino
[Applaudissements]
à
bravo nos bras canot maxime droite avait
dit jeudi que la menace était tout
moment en rémission et toulouse
non ma fille mercy noémie lenoir gomez
et tavarez de gilles paquet brenner
avec le milieu anthony bozzi tito et le
dynamo
jean yanne brune aux yeux
du bonheur
denis parent avec bruno solo alexandra
lamy barbara schulz ça sort le 14 mai et
puis aussi avait à 16 et le zoom
et c'est caméra café la deuxième année
mais les messieurs ewa komorowska j'suis
nous aimons
aux éditions numéro un françoise hardy
et rythmes du zodiaque c'est publié au
cherche midi
sa compilation s'appelle message
personnel
nadine de rothschild
nero t-il sur les chemins de l'âme
si on en avant et ça sort le plus
attention sans le toucher
jean françois bizot un moment de
faiblesse c'est édité chez grasset et
puis aussi la prévision des déclassés
était parue aux agitèrent
n'avancez sonne la crise qu'un
journaliste américain brise la loi du
silence s'était dit et aux arènes
voilà hélène ne pige pas magnifique et
les jugements tamponnais tulipe de gea
capte chicane et hélène de fougerolles
vincent perez et l'eau
didier bourdon et ça fait l'ouverture du
festival hors compétition le 14 mai
soir c'est dans toutes les salles voilà
les tiny touch le triple civile
elle s'appelle au nord-ouest roosbroeck
ça sort le 27 mai et le tout
il sort aussi le 27 mai bruno ce jeu
l'aïe
la semaine prochaine elle est marraine
de la croix-rouge pour la campagne être
solidaire c'est un don collet
nationales de la croix rouge
7 et 10 juillet
et adriana karembeu ira collecter même
l'argent dans la rue voilà je termine
avec reporter sans frontières philip
plisson pour la liberté de la presse
c'est vendu aux produits
reporters sans frontières voilà c'est
fait tout le monde en parle l'émission
où tout le monde pas au rendez vous
je l'aimé
m
[Musique]
trois premiers
key
[Musique]
m
comment
mais
[Musique]